Was macht denn die Wasserflasche hier für nervige Geräusche?
Das hier. Geh mal weg.
Warte mal. So.
Einfach richtig zu.
Vielleicht kriege ich sie klein nicht mehr auf.
So.
Ich bin heute relativ spät am Start.
Oder am Start, wie der Fabian früher immer gesagt hat.
Ich habe mir gedacht, es ist Dezember.
Und zwar mitten Dezember.
Da wird es mal wieder Zeit zu gucken,
was es zur Zeit so für High-IQ-Stellenanzeigen gibt.
Das heißt, wie immer, wenn ihr irgendwelche habt,
die wir uns zusammen angucken wollen, einfach herschicken.
Wobei, muss ich gleich sagen, der Stream ist noch gar nicht richtig angelaufen.
Da sind sechs Leute da. Glaubt nicht.
Da ist da so viel schon was.
Ah, doch, jetzt. Hallo.
Leute, da seid ihr ja.
Ich muss mal kurz meine Arch-Linux-VM anmachen,
weil Arch, by the way, erst mal updaten.
Das nervt mich bei VMWare auch, dass man das nicht wegklicken kann,
während das hier restort.
Warum?
Ich meine...
Hä?
Nicht, dass das eine irgendwie Einfluss auf das andere hätte oder so.
Also, macht eigentlich überhaupt gar keinen Sinn.
So, updaten.
Updaten.
Nein.
Hier auch updaten, alles updaten.
Massive-Update-Stells.
Guck mal hier.
Du Scheiße.
Was ist mit denen los?
Was geht bei JetBrains ab?
Die haben ja alles aktualisiert.
Das neue VMWare-Subscription-Model gibt es nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kenne das neue VMWare-Subscription-Model nicht.
Was ist denn das neue VMWare-Subscription-Model?
Wollen die jetzt auch, dass man ein Abo abschließt?
Dann können sie mich mal, ey.
Ich habe keinen Bock.
Ich habe schon so viele dumme Abos, von denen ich eigentlich viele gar nicht haben will,
aber du nicht mal drum herum kommst.
Richtig hängengeblieben.
Also, ich kenne das neue.
Oder ist das tatsächlich was Gescheites?
Also, ich habe keinen Plan.
Ich weiß nicht, was das neue VMWare-Subscription-Model ist.
Oh.
Exzellente, exzellente.
Forever kills off licenses with only subscript.
Die können mich mal.
Ach, Broadcom gehört das Ganze.
Ja, die Quelle hört sich an nach 0815 AI generiertem Content.
Keine Ahnung, aber ich weiß nicht.
Um was es da genau geht.
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich werde für Forever Workstation definitiv keine Subscription,
noch eine extra Subscription im Monat abschließen.
Irgendwann, irgendwann ist es auch gut mit Subscriptions.
Was, was brauchst du noch alles?
20 Software-Subscriptions, 4 Streaming-Server-Subscriptions, 5 Musik-Subscriptions, 3 Sport-Subscriptions,
Twitch-Subscription, YouTube-Subscription.
Du subscribes dich ja kaputt.
Nee, nee, nee.
Also, irgendwann, irgendwann ist es gut.
Hast du mal Vmware Tanzu verwendet?
Verwendet, also, verwendet kann man nicht wirklich sagen.
Wir haben das auf der Arbeit.
Aber ich habe da keine großen Schnittmengen mit.
Also, ich kenne das, ich weiß, was es ist.
Das ist quasi eine Kubernetes-API-Schicht über Vmware drüber.
Aber ansonsten gar keinen Plan von so selbst basteln.
Vmware Business Transformation, Alter, das hat doch wunderbar funktioniert, Alter.
Was wollt ihr da transformaten?
Simplifying, na klar, natürlich.
Ach so, gut, Vsphere, sonst wie gedöhnt.
Ich glaube, das hat...
Das könnte schon was mit Workstation zu tun haben.
Keine Ahnung, warten wir mal ab.
Ansonsten, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, ich habe...
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt hier Vmware Workstation 17.
Ich glaube, ich habe von den letzten 5 Vmware-Versionen oder sowas von den neuen Features nichts gebraucht.
Dann lasse ich erst mal 17 laufen.
Nein, das wird es auf jeden Fall nicht, weil du dich trotzdem noch ein bisschen mehr selbst darum kümmern musst.
Das ist ja gerade das Schöne an AKS oder an der Google Kubernetes-Geschichte oder an...
Wie heißt das bei AWS?
EKS, gell? Elastic Kubernetes Service.
Die Benahmung bei AWS ist komplett pipiger.
MrWooGame, danke für den Sub.
EKS, ja, genau.
Ja, da ist ja noch sehr viel neues Zeug dabei.
Also, was du da machen kannst.
Also, ich glaube nicht...
Ich weiß es allerdings nicht, weil ich selbst damit...
Wir haben das auch auf der Arbeit, aber ich habe selbst damit bisher sehr wenig Schnittmenge gehabt.
So.
Alles geupdatet.
Pog.
Das ging tatsächlich schneller als gedacht.
Ach so, ja, auch wenn ich die VM jetzt gerade geupdatet habe, ich brauche das gar nicht.
Die Musik ist ein bisschen laut.
So, alles geupdatet.
Nice.
Also, ich habe mir gedacht, es ist Dezember, Leute.
Wird mal wieder Zeit zu gucken.
Was denn alle, die immer schreien, sie finden keine Fachkräfte im Dezember so machen.
So letzte Möglichkeit für viele Leute noch zu kündigen.
Ansonsten wieder drei Monate Kündigungsfrist.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ist das bei euch?
Also, bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitsvertrag weiß ich gar nicht, was ich da für Kündigungsfrist...
Wahrscheinlich ähnlich wie beim letzten.
Aber beim letzten waren es drei Monate zum Quartalsende.
Aber die sind es drei Monate nach Monatsende.
Bei mir sind es, bei mir waren es, beim letzten waren es drei Monate zum Quartalsende.
Das heißt, ich hätte quasi, hätte ich am 01.01. gekündigt, hätte ich quasi noch knapp sechs Monate dableiben müssen.
Das ist schon echt hart.
Deswegen war es letztes Jahr auch für mich so knapp, so wirklich so auf dem letzten Drücker, dass wir das noch hingekriegt haben.
Mit dem neuen Arbeitgeber.
Weil ansonsten hätte ich erst mal gelitten gehabt.
Erst mal ASCII-Quarium anschmeißen zur Entspannung.
Mein Ubuntu-Server ist gelegentlich nicht erreichbar.
Vermute, Docker ist schuld.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Docker daran schuld ist, dass sein Ubuntu-Server regelmäßig nicht erreichbar ist.
Ich würde vielleicht sogar darauf tippen.
Also ich meine, ich weiß ja nicht, was du da drauf machst, ja.
Aber...
Was ist das?
Power Cloud.
Ist ja massive.
Massive Name.
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das überhaupt am Ubuntu-Server liegt, dass der ab und zu mal nicht erreichbar ist.
Es sei denn, du hast irgendeinen Hardware-Defekt oder du machst da drauf irgendwelche ganz abgedrehten Dinger.
Also so wie du das fragst, kann man das zumindest nicht beantworten.
Weil das ist ein ganz klarer großer Ausnahmefall, wenn Ubuntu-Server oder auch Debian-Server, Deluxe-Server, selbst Windows-Server ab und zu nicht erreichbar sind.
Also entweder...
Vor allem wie nicht erreichbar?
Web-Interface nicht erreichbar?
Ist das H nicht erreichbar?
Ping geht gar nicht durch?
Da kann man ja so gar nichts dazu sagen.
Also da brauchen wir schon mehr Informationen und was du machst.
Und selbst dann, glaube ich, gestaltet sich das Remotes zu debuggen als enorm schwierig.
Aber der Chat-Community-Consultant ist am Start.
Also wenn du mehr Informationen erzählst, dann können wir da vielleicht auch was zu sagen.
So.
Chat, geh eine Runde.
Entspannung.
Zack.
Okay.
Ja.
Genug entspannt.
Jobt markant.
Ah, du findest immer Sachen hier am Start.
Ja, gucken wir uns gleich an.
Was war denn das?
Ach, das hatten wir ja das letzte Mal.
Ja, genau.
Schau mal.
Jetzt geht's aber rund hier, ha?
Polizei Bayern.
Stellenanzeige.
Ja, die bezahlen wahrscheinlich wieder nix, oder?
Ja, machen wir.
Ich mein, der Titel ist relativ eindeutig, ne?
Wo hab ich jetzt die was?
Wo hab ich jetzt die Wasserflasche?
Pass mal auf.
Ich hab die Wasserflasche vor zwei Minuten, weil sie mir auf den Keks gegangen ist, mit
den Geräuschen mega fest zugemacht und prophezeit, ich krieg sie jetzt nicht auf.
Mal gucken.
Mal gucken, ob ich sie auf...
Fuck, Alter.
Nee, geht doch.
Geht doch.
Ging doch.
Gar kein großes Problem.
Schau mal das Bild weiter unten.
Okay, ich muss das immer auf dem zweiten Bildschirm checken.
Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration, männlich, weiß, deutsch.
Wie immer.
Systemhaus für Dachau und München.
RBS.net.com.
Was für...
Willst du unsere Echse ausführen?
Ich hab schon cringigeres gesehen.
Ich hab schon...
Aber...
Job bei Sony.
Glaub nicht, dass wir bei...
Alter, die Stellenanzeige von Sony sieht aber auch aus wie 1995, oder?
Oh, das ist mir zu einschläfernd.
Moment, Moment.
Ja, irgendwie sowas hier.
Oder...
Keine Ahnung.
Sowas hier.
Irgendwas...
Ich brauch ein bisschen...
Bisschen...
Nettes Hintergrundgedudel.
Wo...
Aber nicht ganz so einschläfernd ist.
Ja, das ist okay.
Jetzt geht's aber heute Schlag auf Schlag.
Mann, da kommen wir gar nicht...
Wie wär's damit?
Okay.
Ich glaube, Chat.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Wir müssen tatsächlich jetzt anfangen.
Weil...
Ja.
Na ja.
Nein!
Ach du.
Du Hulk.
Na- temple...
Ja.
Oh!
Egal!
Ja.
Achtung!
Seit 6vin discovering es.
Wie gehtk험?
Me-
So, geil.
meter einer meint die letzte er meint die letzte das was ich seit april mache
ja also es hat sich gelohnt im endeffekt also ich meine der alte arbeitgeber hatte
ja schon ab dem zeitpunkt gelitten wo der neue gesagt hat was die kunst
kategorie die twitch das ist das art moment sekunde ich muss das mal kurz auf
dem zweiten alter was zum was ist auf twitch los was zum teufel
alter was geht auf twitch
man ist das sind die twitch wort ist nicht da oder was ist was ist denn mit
twitch auf einmal los die haben doch immer so auf familienfreundlich und safe
für alle und so gemacht haben wir jetzt doch ein bisschen schiss das kick in die
user absaugt oder was wobei ganz ehrlich ich glaube das ist komplett anderes
klientel an was ich das richtet also das wundert mich jetzt doch
ich glaube das ist komplett anderes klientel an was ich das richtet also das wundert mich jetzt doch
die ganze zeit haben sie irgendwelche leute noch gebannt weil die weil die
irgendwie ihr fans profil verlinkt haben oder sowas und jetzt ist das erste dass
irgendwie ihr fans profil verlinkt haben oder sowas und jetzt ist das erste dass das erste was ich aufmache auf meinem
das erste was ich aufmache auf meinem
das erste was ich aufmache auf meinem zweiten forscher bildschirm irgendwelche
zweiten forscher bildschirm irgendwelche
zweiten forscher bildschirm irgendwelche ferrititten bilder alle auf twitch ja ich
ferrititten bilder alle auf twitch ja ich
dachte mir auch, ich dachte mir auch,
die haben gemerkt, dass
der Stuff Geld macht. Ich sag ja schon
seit Jahren, der einzigen
Plattform, der ich es zugetraut hätte,
einen Twitch-Konkurrenten zu
machen, mit halt sowas included, wäre
Pornhub gewesen. Aber gut,
anscheinend hat sich Twitch jetzt gedacht.
Who cares? Auf geht's.
Ja, kannst du
machen, kannst du machen.
Alter, da geht's aber zu sehr.
Okay, auf der anderen Seite,
ich mein,
das ist jetzt erstmal große
im Hype. Mal gucken,
wie das in ein paar Wochen aussieht. Es wird sich
da sicherlich die ein oder anderen Streamer-Sachen
etablieren. Frag mich, was
da alles erlaubt ist. Muss es wirklich
Art sein? Also
darf es nur, muss es gemaltes
Zeug oder computergeneriertes Zeug
oder 3D-Grafiken sein?
Oder können da, können da
demnächst die Leute auch
Booba-Streams machen?
Direkt gebannt? Wo ist das Problem?
Steh ich nicht.
Außer, dass dann irgendwelche Religionsleute
triggert sind.
Aber, da haben sie Pech, wenn sie sich von sowas
triggern lassen.
Also, furry Boobas darfst du, darfst du malen.
Oder wie?
Twerks, twerk, ich kann das nicht mehr aussprechen.
Also, mit dem Popo wagern die Streams sind erlaubt.
Okay, es muss artistic sein.
Also, sprich,
wenn sich da jetzt eine nackig
vor die Kamera legt
und man alles sieht, dann muss
auf dem Bein oder so
irgendein Anime-Bild sein.
Und das ist das, was wir hier machen.
Und so, dann ist das, ist das dann artistic?
Oder, oder wie ist das?
Kunst ist Kunst.
Leugnach für den Sub.
Ach ja, wisst ihr,
ich find's ja, ich find's ja eigentlich nicht schlimm.
Ich find's so lustig, dass sie die ganze Zeit
so super auf safe gemacht haben und
wie gesagt, sogar Leute gebannt haben,
die irgendwie ihr Onlyfans-Profil verlinkt haben.
Oder teilweise über den Umweg
von einem Linked, Linked
Tree ihr Only-Profil, ganz merkwürdiges
Zeug. Und jetzt auf einmal,
das Rippen ist auch
Artistik. Ah ja,
ich geh mal davon aus, die Grenzen werden fließend
sein. Die haben gemerkt,
dass das Kohle bringt. Ich mein, ohne
Scheiß, Onlyfans flutscht,
Pornhub flutscht die Kohle,
das hat, wollte sich bei Twitch,
soll's jetzt auch flutschen, im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Also, ich hab, ich hab mir diese neuen Regeln
nicht angeguckt, mir war das gar nicht bewusst.
Ich war zu sehr im MMO-Kreisel-Crind,
dass da überhaupt, dass ich das
mitbekommen hätte. Aber ich,
mich wundert's, also, mich wundert
nicht, dass das Kohle bringt, mich
wundert's nur, dass die auf einmal so umgeschwenkt
sind von, ähm,
ja, wir stören uns irgendwie an allem, aber
also, ich, also
ich mein, was ich ja, was ich mir noch
eher überlegt hätte, ich mein, das sind ja,
letztendlich sind das ja Amis.
Ich hätt mir gedacht, die machen, also, bevor die,
bevor sowas erlaubt ist,
sind eher, äh, äh,
Firing-Range-Waffen-Shooting-Dinger
erlaubt oder so.
Hell yeah, oder, oder so.
Wobei, ist das, vielleicht ist das sogar
mittlerweile erlaubt. Ich weiß nicht, geht,
darf man Waffen-Streams machen auf Twitch?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich hab
kein Only-Fans-Profil, nur Fansly.
Nur Fansly.
Naja, gut, aber,
um jetzt mal vom aktuellen, vom
aktuellen Twitch-Meta, von dem ich
nichts mitbekommen habe,
wegzukommen, gucken wir uns
mal ein paar Stellenanzeigen an.
Ich, ich muss, ich muss euch jetzt,
ich muss euch doch noch ne Story erzählen.
MickDiät,
ich muss euch, ich muss euch doch noch ne Story
erzählen, und zwar, hier bei mir
in Frankfurt um die Ecke, in Offenbach.
Ich muss jetzt aufpassen, dass ich nicht die Webseiten
dazu erzähle. Nobzi, danke
für den Sub, sonst, sonst
könnte es wirklich Monkatos werden.
Weiß man nicht, ob man überhaupt solche Seiten
hier dann erwähnen darf. Zumindest,
äh, hier in Offenbach, bei mir
um die Ecke,
da gibt es so ne Werbeagentur,
nennen die sich, glaube ich, offiziell,
die,
sind aber nicht so ne 0815-Werbeagentur,
wie man sich das vorstellt, sondern
letztendlich betreiben die ein paar Pornoseiten,
ja, und
ich kenne jemanden, der dort
mal als, als Fisi
die Ausbildung angefangen hat, aber aufgehört hat,
und, äh, eine
Mit-Azubine aus der
Berufsschule, die hat da drei Jahre ihre Ausbildung
gemacht, und Leute,
also,
ich, ich weine ja nur, weil es irgendwie gerade
zum aktuellen Twitch-Meta passt,
aber was die da für Dinger erzählt,
hat, also,
zum Beispiel hat sie erzählt, dass es
total viele Codewörter gibt,
bei diesen Seiten, also zum Beispiel haben
die eine Seite, da konntest du dir
damals
Räumlichkeiten mieten,
für, äh, ja, so
Webcam-Shows und solche Geschichten,
und, ähm,
das wurde dann irgendwie,
ich krieg's nicht mal ganz zusammen, das wurde dann immer mit
irgendwelchen Codewörtern versehen,
dass du wusstest, quasi,
welche
abartigen Sachen
dort gemacht werden können,
ganz weird-champ-Shit, was sie erzählt hat,
und heute,
um jetzt mal den Bogen zu schlagen,
heute machen
die so einen auf super-seriös,
dabei haben sie die ganzen
Seiten immer noch laufen, das hat mich einfach
ein bisschen jetzt an Twitch erinnert, weil
Twitch hat die ganze Zeit auch so auf super-seriös gemacht,
äh, irgendwelche Pornbilder
machen sich halt nicht gut auf der Seite,
auf der Seite, Family-Friendly geht
besser, aber lässt trotzdem die Kohle nicht liegen,
ja, die, die haben's nur umgedreht
gemacht, diese Werbeagentur,
die haben, die haben's nur umgedreht gemacht, die haben
früher Porn-Zeug gemacht, machen's heute
immer noch, aber auf ihrer Homepage
ist das alles
super, super legit und
Werbeagentur, mittlerweile,
keine, keine Spur mehr
von diesem ganzen Zeug, ja,
und zumindest, was ich auch gehört hab von dem Laden, ist, dass
der Chef ein richtiger Spaß sein muss,
der muss auch
ab und zu ins Büro,
reinkommen, wenn er hört, dass die
Leute, äh, einen Witz gemacht
haben und lachen, und da muss der wohl
die Tür aufmachen oder reinschreien, wird hier gelacht
oder gearbeitet, das hat er mir
eins zu eins so erzählt,
Shit,
irgendeinmal macht ein Witz, die Leute
lachen, Chef reißt die Tür auf und
schreit rein, wird hier gelacht oder gearbeitet,
also, netter Laden dort zu arbeiten
anscheinend, ja, ja,
okay, dann,
Updates und so sind durch, dann fangen wir doch mal an
zu gucken, würde ich sagen,
wird hier gelacht oder, das müsste man eigentlich
als Antwort sagen, näher gelacht,
das geht nicht,
ja, ne, da kenn ich, da kenn ich niemand,
da kenn ich
niemand, wie gesagt, ich kenn bloß
zwei Leute von dieser
Werbeagentur in, in Offenbach,
stimmt,
außerdem, außerdem wird bei uns natürlich
nicht gelacht, bei uns wird nur gekeckt,
vielleicht auch keckdoublejude,
bin ich, bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher,
ob, manchmal reicht gekeckt
nicht mehr aus,
so, dann fangen wir mal an, ich will sagen, wir fangen von links nach rechts an,
Sony interessiert mich ehrlich gesagt
nicht, was,
was so,
was ist denn das?
Chat,
was ist das?
Ist das ein Chrome-Feature, oder ist das ein Windows-Feature?
Das ist ein Windows-Feature,
ach, das ist
Power Toys,
ne, was ist denn das?
Was hab ich hier überhaupt an?
Ist das,
power toys exit okay und jetzt ist es jetzt ist es weg okay siehst du mal
wusste ich gar nicht dass sony da ist aber wirklich flashback flashback denn
das ist noch mal kurz gucken was sony ein auge mann mein auge monka ist so
also richtige oldschool stellenanzeige hier von sony
wenn normalerweise brauche ich das nicht um die maus zu finden in spielen wo ich
die maus ich finde habe ich yolo maus an da kann man die maus einfach pink
oder lila oder rosa oder grün oder blau oder gelb oder orange oder so färben
also es ist nicht mal ein transparentes transparentes logo nun ja das ist sie
suchen einen service reliability engineer aha also was was was was was
möchte sony denn haben
station isn't just the best place to play
da kann man sich sicherlich darüber streiten aber pc master race leute werden
sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht gerade bei sony bewährt wobei ganz ehrlich ich
hätte überhaupt keine probleme mit für sony zu arbeiten
ich habe auch keine probleme mit irgendwo wo zu arbeiten was ich
persönlich nicht benutze das juckt mich überhaupt nicht so lange die kohle
stimmt so lange die arbeit stimmt so lange das umfeld stimmt bezahlung
pünktlich ist es auch nicht kohle gibt ordentliche home office regelungen hat
drumherum alles passt ich würde sogar ohne scheiß ich würde sogar für die
bahn arbeiten wenn das alles erfüllt wenn die bahn jetzt sagt max komm her
die bahn ist gar nicht übel ich habe tatsächlich schon einige leute sowohl auf
twitter die mir dort direkt geantwortet haben
ja ich hatte aber auch schon einladungen an meine an meine also an die streaming
an die youtube e mail adresse die ja da steht
niemand der von jemand der bei der bahn am frankfurt in diesem bahn tower oder
so arbeitet und dann an einer db app mit entwickelt ob ich mir das nicht
angucken will also insofern ich glaube so schlecht ist das gar nicht ich glaube
so schlecht ist das gar nicht und ich persönlich auch wenn ich die bahn hasse
wie sonst eigentlich nichts anderes ich würde für die bahn arbeiten wenn die
fat-kohle bezahlt und die arbeitsbedingungen dort und die arbeit
der Laden scheiße ist, werde ich nach wie vor
empfinden. Gehe ich mal von aus. Aber dann
kann ich wenigstens von profitieren, dass sie kacke sind.
Ja, das kann schon... Sag das
aber mal nicht. Ich bin übelst am rumflähen.
Ich habe eine Einladung gekriegt, ob ich mir das nicht
angucken will, bei der Bahn in
diesem
Bahndingstower da in Frankfurt.
Also, insofern
vielleicht meinen immer noch
manche, dass
ich bekehrt werden kann. Aber
die einfachste Art und Weise, mich zu bekehren,
dass die Bahn gut ist, ist, wenn sie einfach
funktioniert. Das ist, glaube ich, das, was die
meisten Leute auch relativ schnell
wieder relativ milde
zur Bahn werden lässt,
wenn es, sagen wir mal, tatsächlich
95%
plus funktioniert.
Ich meine, man darf mal nicht vergessen,
die Bahn ist, glaube ich, so ziemlich das einzige
Unternehmen, was sich eigene Vorgaben
setzen kann, eigene Statistiken
darüber machen kann und trotzdem die Ziele
verfehlt. Da kann man davon ausgehen,
die Ziele sind in Wirklichkeit einfach noch, noch
viel, viel, viel, viel,
viel mehr verfehlt, als das, was
da rauskommt. Was wollt ihr mit
mein Geek-Chat? Also, ich weiß, wer
das ist. Das sind die Pornhub-Betreiber.
Wollt ihr dort arbeiten?
Weiß ich, wie die so sind.
So, also, was will denn, was will denn
Sony haben?
Okay, also, Playstation ist nicht nur der
beste Platz, um zu spielen, es ist auch der beste
Platz in der Welt. Ne, steht nicht da.
Der beste Platz, um da zu arbeiten.
Also, sie sind ganz furchtbar
toll. Im Prinzip ist es die 0815
Stellenbeschreibung schlechthin am Anfang.
Äh, bla, bla, bla.
Sie sind ganz toll. Sie sind noch viel toller.
Sie suchen einen Service Reliability Engineer
in Berlin.
Da hätte ich schon mal gar keinen Bock drauf
auf Berlin, Alter.
Leute, also,
ich bin Frankfurt und Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof
gewöhnt und
eigentlich müsste man
davon ausgehen, fast jede Stadt,
fast jede Stadt ist besser als Frankfurt.
In der Ecke. Frankfurt, drumherum,
ist vollkommen in Ordnung, Leute.
Also, lasst euch nicht so sehr chibäden von meinem
Geschwätz teilweise oder hier
subreddit Frankfurt.
Frankfurt ist vollkommen in Ordnung,
solange es nicht Bahnhofsviertel und umso
mehr man zum Hauptbahnhof kommt, ist.
Es ist, es ist, ansonsten
drumherum gibt's super, ist das ganz,
gar nicht übel in Frankfurt.
So, aber ehrlich gesagt,
was ich bisher von Berlin gesehen hab,
hat mir noch weniger gefallen.
Also, ich kann's, ich kann das
gar nicht so richtig, richtig in Worte, also das,
meine erste, meine erste Erfahrung am
Berliner Hauptbahnhof war, irgendein
Penner, also ich bin rausgekommen
aus dem, aus dem,
was ist denn das, der vordere,
ja, keine Ahnung, der hat zwei Ausgänge, niemand
blickt da durch, wo's, wo's lang geht.
Das erste, was ich hatte, ist ein Penner, der mir ins Gesicht
gewusst hat, direkt am Haupt, an einem der,
der beiden Ausgänge, an beiden der großen
Ausgänge. Hab ich mir gleich gedacht, ey, ist ja wie in
Frankfurt, aber dann alles drumherum,
irgendwie hat, mir hat Berlin so
überhaupt gar nicht gefallen.
Ja, das ist doch nicht, weil der
Berliner Dialekt, ich mein, das ist zwar auch
irgendwie cringe, aber das denken
die von Hessisch und Bayrisch auch, und
also, es gibt ja, es gab
ja mal vor Jahren so eine Umfrage,
so, was der, was der sexiest
und unsexiest Dialekt ist,
unsexiest Dialekt hat
Sächsisch, glaub ich, gewonnen, und Sächsisch,
glaub ich, Bayrisch. Da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen,
für mich ist definitiv
Sächsisch nicht der unsexiest
Dialekt. Also, was ich
überhaupt nicht abkann, ist so
diesen Berliner Dialekt.
Ich hab dit, und sowas.
Das ist so schrecklich,
man. Das,
das kann ich mir nicht geben,
ne.
Ja, dufte, genau.
Sächsisch,
Sächsisch find ich gar nicht so, gar nicht so
schlimm. Nur eine Sache, warum machen
sie im Osten alle nü?
Nü? Weiß ich
nicht. Aber, vielleicht,
vielleicht bin ich, vielleicht bin ich da auch
vorbelastet, dadurch, dass ich
äh, früher täglich mehrere
Stunden mit, mit, äh, Carsten
und dem, und dem Frazier
gelabert hab, aber wobei die beide ja
eigentlich kaum, kaum krassen
Sächsisch Dialekt haben.
Das ist nicht so, dass ich das jetzt
nicht so sehe. Aber ich find den Berliner
Dialekt viel schlimmer. Also,
zumindest, was wollen sie haben? Sie wollen
einen Service Reliability Engineer in Berlin.
Okay, was, was
macht man denn, Bassoni? Was macht man denn,
Bassoni? Also, man spielt,
äh, man spielt eine wichtige Rolle,
oh, das ist, das ist immer,
das ist immer so schwierig, das ist immer so anstrengend,
dieses Business-Zeug zu lesen.
A significant role
in delivering on the promise of
a great cloud gaming experience
to our customers. Okay, also
man arbeitet im Cloud Gaming Team.
Okay, soll alles super
stabil sein. Es sind
jetzt übrigens nicht Site Reliability Engineers,
sondern Service Reliability Engineers,
wahrscheinlich, mehr oder weniger, das gleiche.
Also, drei hauptsächliche
Sachen geht's da. So,
overall ownership of product,
ich bin lost, ich weiß nicht, was das
heißen soll. Das heißt so viel wie
Produktionsverantwortung, vermutlich.
Overall ownership of
production. Okay,
production code quality
and deployments.
Okay, whatever.
Ähm, so.
Wenn man das
hier, successful sich
bewerben will, dann
muss man ein self-directed,
muss man self-direct, also quasi
selbstständig arbeiten, so können
und man muss
auf mehreren Leveln
Entscheidungen mit Trust, okay.
Das ist so krasses
Business-Speak immer alles.
Okay, also was wollen sie?
Profession as a Linux Production
Systems Engineer. Okay, da könnte ich
schon mal bei Sony bewerben. Nicht, dass ich
einen neuen Job suchen würde, mach ich nicht, aber
immerhin. So.
Experience managing large-scale
Web-Service-Infrastructures.
Ah ja, das kann man sagen.
Das kann man so sagen.
Oh, das würde denen wahrscheinlich, also mein
Profil, zumindest für den Punkt, würde
denen wahrscheinlich echt gefallen.
Ähm, so. Also
Erfahrung, was entwickelt, was
Programmiersprachen angeht. Python,
Preferred, Bash, Go, Java, C++.
Leute, ich kann einfach alles,
was sie wollen. Ich kann
Python, ich kann Bash, ich kann Go,
ich kann Rust, ich kann
C++
und wenn ich mir viel Mühe
gebe, kann ich auch Java.
C++ können ist immer so weit
gefasst. Es gibt niemand, der
C++ wirklich kann. So,
zusätzlich,
zusätzlich
wollen sie noch, dass man sich
auskennt mit mindestens
drei verschiedenen von diesen
Topics. Und das erste ist
Distributed Data Storage at Scale.
Okay, ich kenne mich mit Ceph aus,
das ist okay.
Äh, damit habe ich keine Ahnung.
Das ist aber, das ist auch schon,
das ist schon so alt, das ist schon mittlerweile kein Buzzword.
Ja. NoSQL at Scale,
MongoDB, Redis, Cassandra.
Okay.
Alles ziemlich unterschiedlich
her, was, wie das eingesetzt wird,
aber okay. Also das
ist ja, sagen wir mal so eine Distributed Datenbank
im Kern. Das ist eigentlich eher
so eine Memory Cache Geschichte und das ist
eine klassische NoSQL Datenbank, die man
irgendwie clustern muss. Gut.
Data Aggregation Technologies.
Elasticsearch und Kafka. Elasticsearch
kenne ich ein bisschen. Kafka ist so
was, das musst du studiert haben, dass du da durchblickst.
Okay.
Scaling and traditional
relationale Datenbanken, also
Postgres, das habe ich.
Auch wenn ich selbst von SQL,
ich kriege die SQL Basics
hin. Ich kann Inserts machen, ich kann
Selects machen, ich kann was
droppen im Zweifelsfall.
Ich könnte mit sehr viel
Gehirnwindungen auch einen Join machen,
aber muss ich ja auch gar nicht.
Ich muss ja den Kram nur betreiben können. Das habe ich tatsächlich
auch. Das ist das, wo ich mich
hier noch am ehesten sehe. Das ist ein Thema, was
mir enorm viel... Also, ja.
Zumindest der Part, was mir enorm viel Spaß macht.
Systemüberwachung.
Gerade in der Kombination.
Das mache ich wirklich gerne.
Das mag daran liegen,
dass ich in meiner Aus...
Damals in meiner Ausbildung, eines der ersten Sachen
war, die ich gemacht habe, nämlich damals noch
mit Nagios.
Prison Industry, auf geht's zu Sony.
Let's go.
Aber die meinen damit bestimmt nicht nur einfach
mal installiert haben.
Und Incident Management.
Und Incident Tool Sets.
Kubernetes.
End-Ohr-AWS.
Hä?
Das passt nicht zusammen.
Kennst du PRTG?
Ja. Das ist Windows-Owned.
Deswegen habe ich mich damit nie näher beschäftigt.
Das ist ganz
weird. Das hier
ist ein
Cloud-Anbieter.
Und Leute, jetzt könnt ihr
was lernen. Passt mal auf.
Wenn ihr das nächste Mal glänzen wollt
bei euch. Wenn es drum geht,
dass ihr wieder ein bisschen mehr Geld
kriegt. Darkstar, danke schön für den
Prime-Sub und
haben wir sonst noch hier...
Mülli, auch wieder am Start. Danke für die Prime-Subs, Leute.
Ja, also wenn ihr demnächst mehr Geld
haben wollt, dann habe ich für euch
ein richtig nice Buzzword, was ihr hier anbringen
könnt an der Stelle. Wenn euch mal wieder
irgendjemand erzählt,
Cloud-Anbieter, AWS, Google oder sonst
was, dann sagt ihr nicht,
dann sagt ihr, das ist kein Cloud-Anbieter.
Sondern es ist ein Hyperscaler.
Das ist auch ein sehr
beliebtes Wort. Hyperscaler.
Niemand kann damit so richtig was anfangen.
Die meisten
Leute haben sich, glaube ich, mittlerweile drauf geeinigt,
dass Cloud-Anbieter damit gemeint sind.
Aber da müsst ihr sagen
Hyperscaler. Nicht Hyper-Gachi.
Hyperscaler.
Was zum Teufel ist ein Hyperscaler?
Keine Ahnung. Das ist wie bei allen
Buzzwords. Niemand weiß es so genau.
Aber die Leute einigen sich dann
darauf und die Mehrheit
versteht da halt Cloud-Anbieter
drunter. Wir können mal gucken.
What is a Hyperscaler?
...
Achso. Die meinen damit nicht AWS.
Im Prinzip ist das Google, Azure
und AWS und sowas.
...
are large cloud service providers.
Na, wenn Red Hat das sagt, dann muss das auch
stimmen. Deswegen, wenn
ihr glänzen wollt demnächst,
dann sagt ihr nicht mehr Cloud-Anbieter,
sondern ihr sagt, Leute, so müsst ihr das machen,
ihr müsst einfach ab jetzt
immer Hyperscaler
sein. Das ist doch egal, ob Headstand
ein Hyperscaler ist oder nicht.
Da kann man sich,
da kann man sich bestimmt, das ist sogar
besser, wenn du sagst, da kannst du dich dann noch drüber streiten,
ob es das ist oder nicht. Am besten
sagt ihr einfach von heute auf morgen
nur noch Hyperscaler und
irgendwann, so nach einer Woche oder so,
wenn ihr das oft genug gesagt habt,
dann kommt dann irgendwann mal einer zu euch und sagt
euch, sag mal, was
willst du eigentlich die ganze Zeit mit Hyperscaler?
Und dann könnt ihr ihm erzählen,
wie krass
ihr euch auskennt.
Also Hyperscaler ist das.
Zumindest, die zwei
Sachen passen ja nicht wirklich zusammen.
Das eine ist ein Cloud-Anbieter und das andere
ist ein Docker-Cluster.
Um es am möglichst allgemein
zu sagen.
Ein Container-Orchestrierungs-Tool
und ein Cloud-Anbieter.
Also das passt nicht
wirklich end-or-AWS zusammen
an der Stelle. Software-Distribution,
Package-Management-Distribution-At-Scale,
das kann ja auch alles sein.
Configuration-Management,
kenn ich mich auch mit aus. Software-
und Performance-Analyse.
Kommt drauf an, wie tief gehen die...
Also da muss ich sagen, ich glaube,
also ich hab nicht vor, mich dort zu bewerben und
in Berlin schon mal gar nicht, ja.
Aber ich... Das ist tatsächlich eine Stelle,
die passt erstaunlich
gut auf mich. Das würde denen
auf jeden Fall gefallen, was zu dem Punkt
bei mir im Lebenslauf drin steht.
Ich wollte übrigens mal ein Video mit meinem Lebenslauf
machen, fällt mir da gerade noch ein.
Das würde ihnen auch gefallen.
Und ich meine, ich kann im Prinzip auch das
meiste hiervon abdecken.
Also, mindestens
fünf Jahre hab ich. Hab ich.
Hab ich.
Ich hab sogar zehn Jahre plus
Erfahrung.
Ich... Fast 15 Jahre plus
Strong interpersonal written...
Naja gut, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Available to be
scheduled in on-call rotation.
Kein Problem, mach ich.
Wenn ihr Bereitschaft ordentlich bezahlt, kein
Thema. Also wie gesagt, ich such nix Neues.
Ich tu jetzt nur so, als
ob...
Also ich muss sagen, rein von den Anforderungen her
würde das für mich tatsächlich ganz gut passen.
Also,
was, was sind die Benefits bei Sony?
Ja, also.
Da, was, äh...
Naja, gut, ich mein,
dass man, dass man ein Gehalt bekommt,
jeden Monat,
weiß ich nicht, ob das so ein krasser Benefit ist, oder?
Findet ihr es ein Benefit,
jeden Monat Geld zu bekommen?
Also ich, also ich würde sagen, das ist eine
Grundvoraussetzung, kein Benefit.
Wenn du jetzt 26
wärst und versehentlich
Stongs studiert hast,
würdest du eine Ausbildung in der IT anfangen,
oder würdest du wegen des Alters
Stongs machen für den Rest deines Lebens?
Nein, ich würde eine Ausbildung in der IT anfangen.
Und willst du was wissen, wegen des
Alters? Ich hab meine Ausbildung
auch erst mit, äh,
Chatge, ich kann nicht rechnen,
mit 23 angefangen.
Und ich hab davor
auch Stongs gemacht.
Nicht wirklich
Stongs, aber was in
die Richtung. Und das war überhaupt
nicht meins.
Das Einzige, ich hab's schon
500 Mal erzählt, ich weiß, Recycle Story,
das Einzige, was ich mir
von meiner BWL
Ausbildung gemerkt habe, ist,
wie man die Buchhalternase macht,
und dass man linear und degressiv abschreiben
kann. Aber ich hab mich letztens belehren
lassen, degressiv abschreiben geht nicht mehr.
Also ja, würde ich machen.
Wenn du keinen Bock mehr auf Stongs
hast, dann mach das.
Hattest du eine Probezeit bei deiner neuen
Arbeitsstelle, und gibt es bei dir regelmäßig
Feedbackgespräche? Ja, in der Regel.
Ich hatte eine Probezeit, die Probezeit war
ich glaub drei Monate.
Drei Monate?
Ähm.
Ne, sechs, oder?
Ja, sechs Monate.
Ne, sechs Monate war die Probezeit.
Sechs Monate, die ist also jetzt auch
schon rum. Und ja,
es gibt auch regelmäßige Feedbackgespräche.
Eines der Feedbacks,
die ich hatte in letzter Zeit
an meinen Chef, ist, dass ich mir öfters
wünschen würde, mit ihm mal
über aktuelle Sachen zu reden, weil der ist
den ganzen Tag nur am Mieten.
Und man kriegt von ihm nix mit,
und er kriegt von uns nix mit.
Das liegt aber nicht an ihm, sondern
ja, an
dem noch übertriebeneren
Meetingspensum von
Führungskräften
dort in der Versicherung.
Ich mein, bei mir ist
50% des Tages schon Gemiete.
Ich bin nicht seit nem Jahr da.
Ich hab am ersten April angefangen.
Ich bin seit, sag mal,
ich bin seit dem dreiviertel Jahr da.
Wie stehst du zum Studiengang Wirtschaftsinformatik?
Liebe Informatiker, ist das ein guter
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich kann dazu
keine Tipps geben. Ich hab selbst nicht studiert.
Das einzige, was ich immer mitbekomme, ist,
wenn Leute Wirtschaftsinformatik studieren,
die haben meistens keinen Bock auf den höheren Matheanteil
im normalen Informatikstudium.
Ich persönlich würde mich lieber,
also ich, ich persönlich,
und ich muss dazu auch sagen, ich habe nicht vor,
es zu machen. Ich sag's nur.
Also ich persönlich, wenn ich
die Auswahl hätte zwischen BWL-Shit
oder Mathe,
dann würde ich wahrscheinlich lieber Mathe machen
als BWL-Shit.
Wie stressig ist dein Job als
DevOps-Engineer?
Ach, ehrlich gesagt, es geht eigentlich.
Es hat mal immer wieder Phasen, wo
natürlich viel los ist.
Gerade zum Beispiel haben wir
Ende...
Nee, Anfang...
Ende Oktober, Anfang November
gegen neuer Service Life, an dem ich quasi
die letzten paar Monate, quasi seit ich da bin,
mitgearbeitet hab, da ist natürlich auch immer ein bisschen stressig.
Mal kurzfristig.
Aber es geht. Also ich würde sagen, es hält sich
echt so gut in Grenzen,
dass die Burst-Phasen von Stress
mich nicht weiter, nicht weiter
nerven. Und dann hast du auch ein paar, paar
Phasen, wo es dann wieder ein bisschen ruhiger ist und so.
Ey, wo sind wir überhaupt stehen geblieben?
Nee, hier. Bei Sony
waren wir doch. Ok, also Chat,
denkt ihr auch, dass es, dass es
ein Benefit ist, einmal im Monat Geld zu bekommen,
für das, dass ihr da gearbeitet habt?
Ok, es gibt ein
Diskretionsbonus bei Sony.
Also, dass du nicht zufällig
den neuen Playstation
Prototyp mit in die
Kneipe nimmst und dort vergisst,
wie das regelmäßig komischerweise bei
iPhones passiert. Passt nicht
zum Mindset, ne? Das, das
denke ich auch. Das richtig agile
Grindset, High Performer
Mindset arbeitet auch kostenlos.
Solange die Vision
stimmt. Ey, es gibt ne
Unfallversicherung? Ist das
da so gefährlich bei Sony?
Was kannst du zum
als VM empfehlen?
Was? Es ist Berlin!
Stimmt, ich habe vergessen, es ist Berlin!
Ja doch, in Berlin würde ich auch nicht ohne
Unfallversicherung arbeiten.
Ah.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, in Berlin kannst du mal
random angepiekst werden mit
irgendeinem Messer, aber das kann in Frankfurt auch passieren.
Was
meinst du?
As Tower Typ
Was kannst du zum
als VM
empfehlen? Ist einfach das Zoom zu viel?
Was kannst du als VM empfehlen?
Also ich
kann als Virtualisierungslösung
ja, für was denn? Server?
Irgendwie größere Infrastruktur?
Desktop Virtualisierung? Also zur Desktop
Virtualisierung kann ich dir nur
VMA Workstation empfehlen, wie man hier sieht.
Da Linux, da Windows.
Du willst gerne eine VM entwickeln? Also
Desktop Virtualisierung? Nehmen VMA Workstation.
VMA Workstation ist einfach,
finde ich, das mit Abstand angenehmste, was du unter
Windows benutzen kannst. Ich hab so
Windows auf dem Host-System
und hier VMA Workstation
auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Mit meinem i3. Also siehst hier, hier ist
Linux am Start und hier ist
Windows am Start. Ja.
Auch besser als Hyper-V.
Na für Desktop Virtualisierung auf jeden Fall.
Ok, Sony.
Was hatten wir sonst noch?
Mensch, muss mal kurz ins Discord gucken.
Auf dem zweiten
zweiten Monitor.
Hyper-V ist End of.
Was? Nee.
Wirklich? Nein, das glaub ich nicht.
Die haben
doch da richtig Attacke gemacht.
Vor nicht allzu langer Zeit.
Warum sollte das End of Life sein?
Was?
Ernsthaft?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Ach ja.
Ok.
Gut, ich mein, die haben da sehr
viel, also die haben da hart rein
investiert, aber so wirklich
groß durchgesetzt hat sich ja auch Hyper-V
nie. Interessant.
Zumindest, also ich muss sagen,
ich hab mit Hyper-V nie großartig
großartig was, was gemacht.
Aber eine Sache, die ich wirklich cool fand,
ich hab mal ein Video gesehen, äh
ich, nee, Video ist falsch, falsches Wort.
Ich glaub das war so eine Konferenz
Talk von, von
Leuten von Microsoft, die was über
Hyper-V erzählt haben und die hatten
für Hyper-V
ein eigenes Team
Mathematiker,
die den, ja, Core
Source Code von Hyper-V
auf Korrektheit
verifiziert haben. Also sie haben tatsächlich
mathematisch belegt, dass
der Programmcode sich so verhalten
kann, wie es
erwartet wird, beziehungsweise
wahrscheinlich haben sie es umgedreht bewiesen,
dass er sich nicht anders verhalten kann.
Ich mein, vielleicht bringt's
auch was. Seriously, das fällt mir jetzt grad
so ein, wie oft,
wie viele große
Sicherheitslücken in Hyper-V
fallen euch ein, die letzten Jahre?
Mir ehrlich gesagt, so gut wie gar keine.
Auf der anderen Seite muss
ich aber auch sagen, mir fallen auch keine
riesengroßen
VMware-Sicherheitslücken in den letzten
Jahren ein. Könnte das mit
meinem Server eventuell an den
CPU-Shares liegen?
Ich weiß nicht, was du machst.
Du hast immer noch nicht gesagt, was du machst,
oder hast du's geschrieben?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was
du machst. Ich kann nichts dazu sagen.
Bevor du ein bisschen mehr erklärst, was du machst.
Auf Discord.
Hä? Okay.
Ich kann dir nicht
folgen.
Was ist auf Discord?
Gagbait.
Also, wo ich eben gesagt hab, ich muss mal
auf den Discord gucken,
heißt nicht, dass ich irgendwas gesehen hab, was
bei mir im Discord geschrieben wird. Ich wollte Private Messages
gucken. Okay.
Wir waren bei Sony stehen geblieben.
Aha. Okay, dann
lasst uns doch da kurz
reingucken. Nee, nee, ich bin
nicht durch.
Mach ein Screenshot, post es hier.
MayaTV. Ich hab echt absolut keine Ahnung, was du meinst.
So, also wir sind bei Sony stehen
geblieben.
Also man bekommt's, ja gut, man
arbeitet in Berlin. Natürlich muss es
eine Unfallversicherung geben.
Flexibles arbeiten.
Can work from home in agreement with the manager.
Das ist halt auch so ein Ding, das
finde ich immer gut, wenn sie das reinschreiben, dass das prinzipiell
erwähnt ist. Es...
Das Ding ist, dass er ganz
entscheidend
noch nicht mal unbedingt vom Manager
ab, sondern
von der gesamten
Kultur drum herum, weil
die Manager machen
das, was quasi,
ja, so vorge...
vorgegeben, beziehungsweise so
etabliert
ist im Endeffekt. Also
das hört sich für mich nicht so an, als
sagen die jetzt, ey, jo, easy,
bleib mal kurz, bleib mal 80%
der Zeit daheim. Aha.
Okay, was haben wir hier?
Das ist dein Server, der macht,
also, sonderlich
ausgelastet sieht der nicht aus.
Aber was soll man jetzt
anhand, was soll man daran denn jetzt erkennen?
Also, Screenshot
von der CPU-Auslastung, dass die CPU-Auslastung
nicht sonderlich hoch ist. Also
so kann man da nichts mitmachen.
Wie viele Tabs offen?
Naja, ich würde mal sagen, so 100 oder so.
So was.
Vielleicht.
Die Dienste.
Ja.
Und?
Sieht, sieht, sieht
normal aus?
Warum Chromium
anstatt Firefox? Warum nicht
Chromium, Chrome und Firefox?
Heh.
So. Dann gibt es
noch...
Was ist denn eine Public Travel Allowance?
Quasi ne...
Berlin Nahverkehr
Ticket oder was?
Wo kann man Chromium offiziell
downloaden? Naja gut, nachdem das keine
offizielle Sache ist,
du kannst dir Windows-Bills runterladen.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht
so, dass das ein offizielles Produkt
von Google wäre, was du dir runterladen kannst.
Okay, es gibt
wie heißt das?
Geldwerte-Vorteile auf Deutsch
oder so? 40 Euro im Monat.
Hui, Sony, da geht's aber ab.
Christmas-Closer-Dates
da wo man wahrscheinlich dann seinen Urlaub
nehmen muss oder sowas.
Long-Time-Service-Award.
Na geil. Free Softdrinks.
Coffee... Ah!
Obst, Obstteller.
Ganz wichtig.
Vermögenswirksame Leistung.
Das meinte ich doch. Wie habe ich das gerade genannt?
Das meinte ich. Vermögenswirksame Leistung.
Oh, guck mal!
Es gibt ein Playstation Plus
mit Membership.
Na dafür, dafür...
Dafür kann man schon mal ein bisschen auf Gehalt
verzichten, ne?
Das meinte ich.
Okay. Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Alter!
Ich... Also...
Mach mal langsam.
Mach mal langsam mit Posten.
Du musst, du musst schon
etwas mehr
schreiben, was
genau das Problem ist und was Sache ist.
Das sind irgendwelche random Schnipsel, die überhaupt
keinen Sinn ergeben.
Was ist Docker?
Willst du mich veräppeln oder ist das irgendwie
Cheapbait?
Ich habe absolut nicht den leisesten Schimmer, was du willst.
Glaube ich auch mittlerweile.
Obst.
Das ist das falsche. Nein, das ist auch das falsche.
Eigentlich wollte ich das Cheapbait machen.
Eigentlich...
Eigentlich wollte ich den ja machen.
Richtig hartes Cheapbait.
Also ist natürlich die Frage,
wie viel Geld Sony bietet.
Nur weil es Sony ist,
heißt es nicht zwangsläufig, dass es viel
Kohle gibt, ja?
Was haben wir hier unten noch?
Ja, okay.
Alles klar.
Also.
Ich habe seriously keinen Bock in Berlin
zu arbeiten, aber
ich glaube, dass denen tatsächlich
mein Lebenslauf hierfür ganz gut gefallen
würde. Weil ich erfülle
bis auf so eine Kleinigkeit,
ich erfülle einfach alles,
was die haben wollen.
Okay, da kann man sich drüber streiten,
ja? Aber ansonsten,
ich habe sogar noch mehr, als die haben wollen.
Sowohl hier, als auch
hier, als auch hier.
Also ich glaube, mein Lebenslauf würde Sony
in dem Fall tatsächlich gut gefallen.
Aber ich werde mich nicht bewerben, weil ich suche keinen Job.
So, next.
Was haben wir sonst noch? Ach Leute,
wenn ihr irgendwas habt und falls ihr irgendwas übersehen habt,
könnt ihr ruhig
reinschicken. Wir gucken uns das dann alles heute Abend an.
Nur mal so, falls ich
Subscriptions übersehen habe,
ich gucke jetzt gerade noch mal rein.
Mülli ist am Start, DarkSide ist am Start,
Nobzi, MacDiät,
Loki, MrMoogame,
da haben wir noch Arnab
und MartyMcFly vor zwei Tagen.
Dankeschön für die Subs, Leute.
Massive Subscriptions hier.
Pog.
So, also.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Moin, Noah.
Also, so. Fangen wir von links nach rechts an.
Das sollte ich mir auch angucken, hat einer gepostet.
Also, wir akzeptieren das.
Wir werden erstmal richtig
geblendet.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Ein Plattform-Engineer G.N.?
Jetzt hört es bei mir aber auf
mit den Abkürzungen.
Gender Neutral?
Warum ist das überhaupt ein Thema?
Ich meine, who cares?
Ob es ein Typ ist
oder nicht?
Oder ein
Fahrrad oder sonst was?
Ich, ganz ehrlich, würde ich
jemanden suchen,
es sei denn,
es ist gesetzlich vorgeschrieben,
das zu machen,
ich würde mir alle geeigneten
Kandidaten angucken
und mir wäre es scheißegal,
als was
sie sich identifizieren.
Hauptsache, sie haben es technisch drauf.
Es ist mir vollkommen wurscht.
Die können sich als Achterbahn identifizieren
oder als Mann, als Frau,
als...
ob es hinter dem
Holzwelt noch dafür
28 verschiedene Sachen gibt.
Es wäre mir vollkommen egal.
Solange die Ahnung haben von dem,
was sie machen.
Danke für den Sub.
Seriously, was juckt's mich?
Solange die gut sind in ihrem Job,
was juckt's mich?
Das ist ja keine Partnervermittlung.
Mir ist es wurscht, als was die sich identifizieren.
Das können die für sich machen?
Das geht mich als Arbeitgeber
eigentlich auch gar nichts an.
Da fehlt, da fehlt ein bisschen was.
91, 96, 97, was sind die verbleibenden 3%?
Also, was, äh, Powercloud, von denen habe ich noch nie was gehört.
Also, was machen die denn?
Hört sich ein bisschen an Elektroauto an oder was ist das?
Möglich Macher der Energiewende.
Okay.
3% keine Angabe, aha.
Also, seit 2012 gestalten wir als IT-Unternehmen gemeinsam mit unseren Kunden und Partnern...
Okay, bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Okay, sie suchen einen Plattform-Engineer.
Deine Mission.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube das einfachste mittlerweile wäre tatsächlich, wenn man diesen ganzen Krempel einfach weglassen würde.
Dann kannst du auch nichts falsch machen.
So, also.
Bist du bereit?
Dich einem Team von Technologie-Experten anzuschließen und an Cloud-Infrastrukturen und Anwendungs-Architekturen mitzuarbeiten.
Wenn ihr wollt und es ordentlich bezahlt, why not?
Ich meine, es ist im Prinzip genau das, was ich aktuell mache, ja.
Als, ach hier, okay, hier nennt sich jetzt zur Abwechslung mal Site-Reliability-Engineer.
Was für ein Begriff ist, der sich immer mehr durchsetzt?
Das wäre auch geil.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr bewerbt euch da über die Homepage, ja.
Ihr seid im ersten Online-Teams-Call und die machen so auf Motivation und fragen euch.
Und, Herr Bewerber, sind sie bereit, sich einem Team von Technologie-Experten anzuschließen, an Cloud-Infrastrukturen und Anwendungs-Architekturen mitzuarbeiten?
Und du sagst einfach, nein, keck lief.
Aber du musst es genau so sagen.
Du sagst, nein, keck lief.
Und dann musst du den Call beenden.
Wichtig ist jetzt das Emote dahinter.
Aber das Emote ausgesprochen.
Nein, keck lief.
Dann sind sie erstmal verwirrt und wissen nicht, was keck lief ist.
Und denken dann erst, Teams hatte irgendeine Verbindungsstörung oder sowas.
Keck lief.
Oder noch besser.
Du sagst, nein, keck lief.
Gehst aus dem Bild raus.
Und dann springst du zurück auf den Schuh und sagst, she baited.
Okay, da bist du schon mal komplett durchgefallen wahrscheinlich.
Es sei denn, das sind Twitch-Emote-Enjoyer.
Man kann doch in Teams auch GIFs posten.
Stimmt, dann sagst du einfach, nein, postest keck lief als GIF.
Halbe Apo-Red-Prank.
Ja, da sind wir stehen geblieben.
Also, als Site-Reliability-Engineer bist du Vordenker.
Bei der Entwicklung und Implementierung...
...von DevOps-Prozessen in Cloud-Umgebung und Container.
Das ist, da sehe ich mich.
Genau mein, äh, ist das Metier?
Oder wie sagt man da?
Genau mein Bereich.
Du automatisierst Continuous Integration und Continuous Delivery bis zum Geht-Nicht-Mehr.
Und wirbst Live-Probleme.
Und sicherlich hast du unseren Kunden keine Ausfälle erlebt.
Ey, ehrlich gesagt, ich finde, das würde für mich auch ganz gut passen.
Das ist genau so mein Ding hier.
Aber, ne, also, ich muss das halt immer...
...hunderttausendmal Sachen, weil sonst die Frage kommt.
Nein, ich suche nicht schon wieder was.
Aber ich versetze mich mal immer so in die Rolle rein, dass ich was suche.
Ich finde, normalerweise sind ja diese ganzen Sachen immer super cringe geschrieben.
Das hier geht, das spricht mich sogar teilweise irgendwie ein bisschen an.
Mein Milieu?
Mein Hood, sozusagen.
Wo brauchen wir dich?
An diesen Standorten oder Remote innerhalb Deutschlands kannst du unser Team verstärken.
Aachen, Leipzig.
Schon wieder Berlin, Mann.
Keck, lief.
Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Deine Aufgabenbereiche.
Okay, was haben wir?
Analysier das Plattform...
Okay, die sind in AWS, also man baut Cloud-Infrastruktur auf.
Du entwickelst unser internes Plattform-Tool PHP.
Weiter.
Welches den Development-Teams die Möglichkeit gibt, ihre Dienste einmal selbst zu gestalten.
Okay.
Naja, mein...
...historisch gewachsen, deswegen mit PHP.
So, du designst und implementierst DevOps-Prozesse in Cloud-Umgebungen sowie Container-Technologien.
AWS, Azure, Docker.
Okay.
Du entwickelst und verbesserst die Continuous Integration und Continuous Delivery Automatisierung weiter.
Das passt eigentlich alles ganz gut, ja.
Chat, wer auch immer das gepostet hat, habt ihr das gepostet, weil ihr euch da vielleicht bewerben wollt?
Na, ich würde nicht sagen, dass das ein Fehler ist.
Ich würde sagen, die meinen tatsächlich beide Cloud-Anbieter an der Stelle.
Du analysierst und behältst Störer im Live-Betrieb und stellst sicher, dass unsere Kunden nicht von Ausfällen betroffen sind.
Du arbeitest eng.
Die haben dich abgelehnt.
Okay.
Naja.
Hätte ja sein können, dass du dich da bewerben wolltest.
Wusste ich ja nicht.
Wer nutzt zwei unterschiedliche Cloud-Anbieter?
Da kenne ich tatsächlich einige, die das machen.
Aber da ist es meistens hauptsächlich Azure plus X.
Und X ist dann entweder AWS oder Google.
Und...
Es ist meistens so, dass viele Azure Active Directory benutzen.
Und dann vieles von anderen Cloud-Anbietern, aber auch von Azure.
Aber ich habe mich ja belehren lassen.
Chat, ihr müsst mir mal auf die Sprünge helfen.
Das heißt ja nicht mehr Azure Active Directory, sondern es heißt jetzt, wer weiß es, Entra.
Okay, Entra.
Es ist so dumm alles bei Microsoft.
Weißt du, Azure Active Directory.
Jeder kennt Azure, also Azure Active Directory.
Voll und ganz easy Bezeichnung.
Konnte sich jeder merken.
Entra kann sich keiner merken.
Ich werde mir das nie...
Ich brauche ewig, bis ich das im Kopf habe.
Ich meine, es sagt doch auch...
Chat, sagt ihr Office 365 oder Microsoft 365?
Oder sagt ihr einfach nur Office?
Wie seid ihr her?
Also die meisten Leute, die ich kenne, sagen tatsächlich einfach nur Office.
Die meisten Leute sagen einfach nur Office.
Oder Office 365.
Aber Microsoft 365 sagt mir so gut gar keiner.
Ja, das sage ich auch.
Aber ihr kennt ja meine Meinung, was Office-Produkte angeht.
Aus meiner Sicht hat das eigentlich alles gar keine Daseinsberechtigung, bis auf Excel.
Und ich verwende es auch nicht.
Kannst du GitHub Pull-Requests bewerten und sagen, ob man cool ist oder nicht?
Oh.
Schick her.
Habe ich noch nie gemacht und ich weiß nicht, ob ich den coolenes Faktor eines GitHub Pull-Requests ordentlich bewerten kann.
Aber ich kann es ja mal probieren.
Möglich, aber wusste sofort, was es ist.
Hey, ich benötige eure Hilfe.
Ich mache gerade ein Praktikum in einem großen Systemhaus und habe ein Ausbildungsangebot bekommen.
Aber das Team ist jetzt nicht das Beste.
Also wenn du von Anfang an weißt, dass es ein scheiß Laden ist, dann würde ich da keine Ausbildung machen.
Es sei denn...
Du musst irgendwie...
Ist das für dieses oder für nächstes Jahr?
Weil dieses Jahr ist eigentlich schon gelaufen, ne?
Weil wenn das für nächstes Jahr ist,
dann würde ich sagen, guck, ob du nicht was anderes findest.
Auf der anderen Seite hier weißt du wenigstens, was kacke ist,
weil du schon Einblicke hattest.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn man es schon kacke findet,
bevor man dort überhaupt anfängt,
dann ist die Chance hoch, dass man da nicht glücklich wird.
Für nächstes Jahr.
Dann probier lieber nochmal woanders was zu finden.
Denn da musst du dich ja auch nicht
innerhalb der nächsten 1-2 Wochen entscheiden.
Das hat ja wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen Zeit.
Dann würde ich lieber mal rumgucken
und vielleicht findest du irgendwas anderes,
was dir mehr zusagt.
Also ganz ehrlich, es gibt ja immer...
Wisst ihr, welchen Spruch ich überhaupt nicht mag?
Das ist diese Geschichte von
Ausbildungsjahre sind keine Herrenjahre.
Das ist so der mega...
Gibt es einen Spruch, der mehr Boomer ist als der?
Ich finde, das ist der boomerischste
Spruch überhaupt.
Das ist so schlimm.
Also ich meine,
natürlich,
natürlich kannst du in deiner Ausbildung
nicht der nächste Abteilungsleiter sein.
Das ist schon klar.
Was der Spruch bedeuten soll,
ich glaube, das ist immer kontextabhängig.
Aber im Prinzip soll das so viel heißen wie
in der Ausbildung muss man halt auch
durch viel Mist aushalten.
Weil die jetzigen Ausbilder...
Du musst einstecken können,
weil die jetzigen Ausbilder mussten das in ihrer Ausbildungszeit auch.
Ich finde das komplett verkehrt, den Ansatz.
Was ist das für eine Welt,
wo du deine Auszubildenden scheiße behandelst,
nur weil du selbst in der Ausbildung scheiße behandelt wurdest?
Was ist das für eine bescheuerte Denkweise?
Und dann muss man sich noch beschweren
und sagen,
ah, aber die jungen Leute,
die wollen alle nichts mehr arbeiten
und wir finden auch überhaupt keine mehr.
Und die Azubis haben ja einen viel zu hohen Anspruch.
Und was auch immer.
Also das ist echt richtig, richtig viel Pega.
Ja.
Ich überlege mich auf eine IT-Manager-Stelle zu bewerben,
obwohl ich in dem geforderten Bereich
nur die praktische Erfahrung als Admin habe.
Was meinst du, kann das gut gehen?
Ehrlich gesagt,
wenn du gar keine Erfahrung in dem Bereich hast,
würde das wahrscheinlich nicht
für die...
für die Leute,
die das approven,
sprechen,
wenn sie dich da ins kalte Wasser werfen,
ohne jegliche Vorbereitung.
Ich denke, sinnvoller wäre es,
an der Stelle zu sagen,
okay, wir sehen,
also dass dein Chef sagt,
okay, so, so, ich sehe,
du möchtest dich gerne in eine Management-Richtung weiterentwickeln.
Was hältst du denn davon,
wenn du mal ein paar Inhouse-Kurse dafür besuchst
oder dich damit erst mal ein bisschen drauf vorbereitest,
bevor du von heute auf morgen Manager wirst?
Weil ich habe es ganz oft erlebt,
auch in der alten Firma,
wo ich gewesen bin,
dass so dieses,
man wird jetzt vom Admin zum Manager,
eigentlich,
mir fällt ehrlich gesagt kein Fall ein,
wo das geklappt hat.
Ich meine, wenn du da Bock drauf hast,
ist schon mal die Voraussetzung.
Aber ich weiß nicht,
ob es ganz ohne Erfahrung die beste Entscheidung ist,
das zu machen.
Ich meine, was spricht denn dagegen,
dass du mal, ohne dass du jetzt von Admin
zu Manager wirst,
mal ein bisschen dir das anguckst.
Du kannst das ja mal irgendwo als Vertretung machen.
Du kannst ja mal gucken beispielsweise,
dass du in irgendeinem Projekt mitarbeitest,
vielleicht auch irgendwie den kleinen Teilbereich verantwortest,
was auch immer,
bevor du zu einer kompletten Managerstelle wechselst.
Weil wenn du jetzt,
wenn dir das hier gefällt,
dann ist die Chance wahrscheinlich sehr hoch,
dass dir eine komplette Managerstelle nicht gefällt.
Es mag sicherlich die ein oder anderen Admins geben,
die gute Manager sind,
aber meistens ist es so,
würde ich jetzt einfach mal behaupten,
dass ein Großteil der guten Admins
nicht gute Manager sind
und noch ein viel größerer Teil der Manager
keine guten Admins sind.
Oder nein, nimmt sich wahrscheinlich nichts.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob so eine...
Ich kann nur immer von mir sprechen,
ich kenne dich nicht,
aber ich weiß,
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass das eine gute Idee ist.
Also wenn du sagst,
ich will das machen,
dann würde ich nicht sagen,
ich springe jetzt von heute auf morgen ins kalte Wasser
und ganz ehrlich,
wenn ich dein Chef wäre,
würde ich dich auch nicht da vorschlagen für die Stelle,
wenn ich wüsste,
dass du überhaupt keine Erfahrung hast,
und je nachdem,
ich meine,
würde ich dich besser kennen.
Also dann würde ich wahrscheinlich eher zu dir sagen,
hey, wie sieht es aus?
Wollen wir nicht gucken,
dass wir das vielleicht mal in nächster Zeit
dir das ermöglichen,
dir das anzugucken
und dass du dich in die Richtung entwickelst,
anstelle von heute auf morgen Manager zu werden.
Polkadot SDK, was ist das?
Polkadot muss ich immer anders...
Kennt ihr dieses gepunktete Trikot aus der Tour de France?
Das heißt doch auch so.
Okay, also dann machen wir das.
Ich bewerte den Pull-Request jetzt auf Coolness,
Leute, habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob ich das wirklich bewerten kann,
weil...
Ach, ach, guck mal.
Ach, deswegen kam mir das bekannt vor.
Das habe ich doch schon mal gehört.
Ich bin ja bei uns auf der Arbeit auch an einem Blockchain Projekt.
Ich bilde mir ein,
das habe ich tatsächlich schon mal irgendwo gehört.
Blockchain-Shit, ja.
Okay, du hast...
Oh, es ist in Rust.
Na, damit steigt der Coolness-Faktor schon mal.
Ähm...
Äh...
Piwoll, ich habe eine Idee.
Was hältst du davon,
wenn wir uns das jetzt zusammen angucken
und dann darf der Chat abstimmen,
ob das ein cooler PR ist oder nicht?
Also ich finde,
der Coolness-Faktor steigt enorm,
dadurch, dass es ein Rust-Projekt ist.
Weil die richtig coolen Leute,
sind blazingly fast in Rust.
Du hast sogar Tests geedit.
Das ist noch nicer.
Blockchain zieht es vielleicht runter?
Na, ich weiß nicht.
Das ist sicherlich Ansichtssache.
Für mich nicht.
Für mich ist es neutral.
Okay.
Ja, nice.
Ich...
Ich finde...
Also schon gut geschrieben.
So, Files changed.
Jetzt gucken wir uns mal den Rust-Code an.
Oh, der sieht auch noch voll gut aus.
Der sieht auch noch voll Rust-mäßig aus.
Guck mal hier.
Mit Magic-Rust-Syntax.
Und Kommentaren da oben drüber.
Meine Güte, ey.
Keck, wait.
Okay, was du da machst,
habe ich keine Ahnung von.
Aber es...
Es sieht sehr Krustentier-mäßig aus.
Okay.
Oh, oh.
Sind die Tests...
Sind das die Tests?
Ne.
Migration?
Was?
Hast du da ganz schön Arbeit reingesteckt, oder?
Bis das alles so fertig war.
Da hast du bestimmt ein bisschen dran gesessen.
Oder?
Also ich finde es gut.
Ich finde, das ist ein nicer Pull-Request.
Okay.
Dann machen wir jetzt eine Abstimmung.
War das ein cooler Pull-Request?
Ja?
Nein?
Ähm.
Ich brauche noch eine dritte dumme Antwort.
Nein, wir brauchen keine dumme Antwort.
Es gibt auch keine additional votes mit Keksen,
weil sonst geht das wieder 50-50 aus.
Okay, Chat-Girl.
Was meint ihr?
Hat sich über einen Monat gezogen mit Feedback?
Ja.
Das dachte ich mir.
Guck mal.
Man sieht ja auch hier,
da wurde auch einiges hin und her geschrieben und sowas.
So richtig kaltherzige Leute wieder im Chat.
Nein.
Keckleaf.
Alles scheiße.
Keine guten Pull-Requests.
Alles kacke.
Die Rust-Hater.
Genau.
Weil du nicht verstehst, was es ist.
Ich auch nicht.
Darum geht es nicht.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was er da genau gemacht hat.
Okay.
Also, hier hast du es.
Schwarz auf Weiß.
Approved.
Kannst du dir Screenshotten und den Lebenslauf einfügen.
Wo bloß Chat bestätigt.
Das war ein cooler Pull-Request.
Okay.
Ja.
Rep manifold Request.
Pog.
Und nicht zu sagen.
і
surgeons.
Gut.
Machen wir mal weiter.
Wo sind wir eigentlich stehen geblieben?
Hier beim Plattformen-Engineer.
Nein, im Chat.
Leute.
Da komme ich.
Wir machen.
Wir harken jetzt erst Mal den Plattform-Engineer ab.
Sonst komme ich dem überhaupt nichts hinterher.
Nein.
Wir müssen erst mal den Chat abhaken.
Weil ansonsten bin ich soweit hinten dran.
Für wie viel Prozent mehr Gehalt würdest du wechseln, wenn sonst alles passt?
bei deiner jetzigen stelle also gehen wir davon aus mir gefällt es wirklich gut da wo ich aktuell
bin muss ich sagen ja also wohl also gehen wir von aus geht also tomo gehen wir davon aus dass
die neue stelle quasi mindestens auf dem niveau ist bei allem wie die alte plus mehr geld ja weil
es schon gut also ich mag die leute ich mag die arbeit gerade was cloud diese ganze cloud und
blockchain thematik angeht das ist einfach so richtig bleeding edge schritt ich finde die
home office regelung gut ich finde das gehalt gut ich finde gut dass mein lieblings kollege aus dem
letzten laden mitkommen konnte und das für die kantine haben und es gibt jede menge sachen die
ich gut finde also ich habe echt keine absichten zu wechseln also wenn man davon ausgeht dass das
also gehen wir davon ausgehen dass es exakt im neuen laden geht so wäre wie jetzt plus mehr
geld
also dass ich den aufwand und das hin und her und das wechseln und das neue eingewöhnen auf mich
nehmen würde würde ich schon sagen 20 prozent mehr müssten sein wenn ihr noch blockchain def sucht
kannst du mir nicht mache ich mache ich erinnere mich noch mal dran im chat ich bin nämlich gerade
nicht auf der arbeit ich bin ich habe urlaub des ersten ich glaube nicht dass wir polka dot rust
developer suchen aber wenn wenn dann schlage ich dich vor und das gute ist wenn ich die vorschlage
kriege ich sogar provision der provision kann man es nicht nehmen werbe werbe prämie oder so bei
welchem unternehmen würdest du eine ausbildung starten was richtung klauen der keine ahnung
mein ausbildungs betrieb gibt es auch nicht mehr also da schon mal nicht das haben wir
auch da wo ich die ausbildung gemacht habe da hatten wir teilweise irgendwie ja die 50 azubis
als billige arbeitskräfte mal eine frage ich habe eine mutter neues handy gekauft und auch keine action
und erbarmt sich keiner der bucklingen
Verwandtschaft, ihr das Handy einzurichten
und sie will warten, bis ich
zu Besuch komme Anfang April.
Macht das irgendwelche Probleme, es so lange liegen zu lassen?
Nö. Außer, dass du es nicht
mehr umtauschen kannst.
Wobei, du hast... Ach, online in die
Mediamarkt, ja gut, dann, wenn es
Probleme hat, kannst du es halt nicht mehr umtauschen.
So ohne weiteres, ne?
Kannst immer noch sagen, ist kaputt, innerhalb von
sechs Monate und so, ja. Aber
ist halt halt schwieriger.
Kann ich das nicht mal...
Kann ich das nicht alleine wenigstens einschalten?
Und du sagst dir, was du drücken musst?
Das kriegen die doch meistens hin.
Das machen wir heute nicht.
Sagt mir nix.
Wie ist deine Erfahrung mit der
Arbeitsmoral der jungen Generation?
Ist mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt...
Weiß ich grad nicht.
So, jetzt haben wir den Chat
geschafft, wir machen weiter, ja.
Also, hier sind wir stehen geblieben.
Du arbeitest eng mit Softwareentwicklern,
Architekturteams, okay, das ist...
Du stimmst dich direkt.
Mit internen Stakeholdern,
ah, da werden wir doch
die Stakes geschwenkt.
Unsere Anforderungen.
Also bis jetzt fand ich das gar nicht so übel hier.
Unsere, unsere, unsere
Anforderungen. Du hast ein abgeschlossenes
Studium in Informatik oder Wirtschaftsinformatik.
Wie?
Vergleichbar...
Nicht oder vergleichbare Ausbildung?
Gibt's nicht?
Das...
Wollen die trotzdem?
Weil ich mein, seriously,
who cares, wenn einer vor 5
oder 10 Jahren
ein Wirtschaftsinformatikstudium abgeschlossen hat?
Du bist erfahren in der Programmierung mit
PHP und Frameworks für Symfony.
Da muss ich sagen,
das passt bei mir nicht.
Ja, das am Anfang hätte gut gepasst, aber das hier gar nicht.
Du konntest bereits
Erfahrung in Designimplementierung
mit den von Cloud... Ja gut, das ist natürlich sinnig.
Für so eine Stelle.
Wollen die jetzt eigentlich jemand,
der schon
länger Erfahrung hat oder
nicht? Das kann ich jetzt nicht
so richtig da...
Weil das ist, das ist ja sehr
vage. Also, du konntest
bereits Erfahrung. Das ist so,
das ist so...
Große Interpretationsfrage.
Du automatisierst lieber
einmal mehr richtig als Dinge zweimal
zu tun. Das finde ich ist eine bescheuerte
Ansicht.
Die Aussagen gibt's öfters, aber die finde ich
total bescheuert.
Diesel12, danke schön für den Sub.
Das finde ich total bescheuert.
Ach, du hast noch einen Sub
gegiftet. Pogu, danke schön.
Die Aussage finde ich total
bescheuert. Also, ich
verstehe den Hintergrund. So nach dem
Motto, wenn man jetzt zum
hundertsten Mal einen Server aufbaut, dass man es
da mit Ensemble richtig macht und so. Da sage
ich überhaupt nichts zu. Wenn man öfters
Cloud-Infrastruktur hinstellt,
abreißt, das mit Terraform richtig zu machen,
ist gut. Aber wenn das was ist,
was noch in der...
in der Erprobung ist,
da macht es oftmals keinen Sinn,
so, ja,
so fließend wie das ist,
da großartig was zu automatisieren.
Und da macht man trotzdem
Dinger zwei, dreimal, ja.
Also, wenn man gerade irgendwie erprobt,
oh, fällt mir jetzt gerade
kein gutes Beispiel für ein, ja,
irgendeine Software, wenn man jetzt irgendwas ausprobiert,
ja, nehmen wir doch mal, nehmen wir doch mal
das, was ich
in letzter Zeit, die letzten paar Monate auf der
Arbeit ausprobiert habe, ja. In der Google
Cloud, welche Infrastruktur-Kombination
ist am schnellsten für unsere
Blockchain-Kisten, ja. Da habe
ich mehrfach Linux-Kisten auf- und
abgebaut, ja. Und
wisst ihr, was ich auch...
Was ich da... Das Einzige, was daran
automatisiert war, war
ein bisschen rüberkopiere von der alten
Kiste. Ich meine, letztendlich, ich
hab die... Ich hab die noch nicht mal mit Terraform
aufgebaut. Wozu? Du klickst
dreimal auf Weiter,
zumal ich immer andere Konfigurationen
für die VM gebraucht habe, ja, mal mit Lokal,
mit allen SSDs, mal mit Netzwerk-Storage
und sonst was. Du klickst die VM an,
dann kopierst du dir ein paar Sachen rüber
und startest ein paar
Sachen neu. Das hätte ich automatisieren
können, aber es war auch überhaupt nicht
klar, was da am Ende rauskommen soll.
Deswegen, es macht, finde ich, und
ich behaupte auch einfach mal, das war viel weniger
zeitaufwendig, als das irgendwie
jetzt zu automatisieren an der Stelle.
Ja, also,
dem Gedanken gebe
ich prinzipiell recht,
aber
das so
strikt auszulegen, finde ich bescheuert.
Und den Satz habe ich schon öfters gehört und ich
fand ihn jedes Mal bescheuert.
Es ist wie bei allem, es muss
kosten-nutzen-mäßig sich lohnen.
Und man kann selbst sagen,
hey, und wenn man Sachen macht,
einmal im Jahr,
die eine Viertelstunde dauern,
aber die zu
automatisieren, würde
viel komplizierter... Also,
zum Beispiel, ich hab ein Beispiel
für euch. Eine Sache,
die ich automatisiert habe, auf der
alten Arbeit, die aber
zumindest fragwürdig ist, zu
automatisieren. Je nachdem,
wie oft sie vorkommt. Und zwar,
es gab bei uns
ein
Anbieter, der hat unsere Mails,
also beim alten Arbeitgeber,
nach Spam gefiltert.
Und da sind
ab und zu E-Mails im Spam
gelandet und da gab es an
unseren Support ein
Task,
dreimal am Tag,
mussten die sich einloggen, im Web-Interface
von diesem Spam-Filter-Anbieter
und alle E-Mails freigeben,
die im Spam-Ordner gelandet sind. Fragt
nicht, warum, aber so musste
das gemacht werden. Hat spezielle
Hintergründe, warum das gemacht werden muss.
Und
die haben keinerlei
API gehabt zum Ansprechen.
Wir haben übrigens ein paar Mal mit denen
telefoniert und ein paar Mal auch, wo es
drum ging, ob der Vertrag verlängert wird und so was,
wurde auch drauf angesprochen, Leute,
warum habt ihr nicht eine API, um das irgendwie zu automatisieren?
E-Mails freigeben und so was.
Und wisst ihr, was die Antwort war von denen?
Ah ja, das ist eine gute Idee.
Da gibt es schon bei uns einen internen
Feature-Request.
Und damit haben sie sich irgendwie
abspeisen lassen. Was juckt mich
als Anwender draußen, ob es bei denen schon
einen Feature-Request gibt? Das scheiß funktioniert nicht.
Es juckt mich doch null, ob die da
intern schon irgendeinen Feature-Request für haben.
Naja, zumindest, was ich dann gemacht
habe, ist, ich habe
Browser-Automatisierung,
mich im Land der
Browser-Automatisierung versucht.
Kennt ihr Puppeteer?
Das ist ein Fernsteuerungs-
Framework für Chrome.
Und
da habe ich
ein Tool gebaut,
was Chrome fernsteuern kann
und was dann im Web-Interface
rumklickt
und Spam freigibt.
So, und jetzt überlegt euch mal,
man hätte so eine
Aufgabe, und das hat einige Tage,
gebraucht, bis das wirklich ordentlich funktioniert.
War das zufällig Hornetsicle?
Nein, war es nicht. War es was anderes.
Ich sage euch nicht, welcher das war.
So, und wenn man das jetzt
nur einmal im Monat für eine Viertelstunde
machen sollte, ist halt echt
fraglich, ob sich
das dann lohnt, kurz zu automatisieren.
Zumal die Automatisierung auch enorm
fehleranfällig ist.
Weil sobald sich die Webseite von
denen ändert, und das kam auch öfters mal vor,
musste ich meine Autos
automatisiert anpassen.
Also, das ist halt das Ding.
Kann man nicht rüber schreien.
Also, das einzige um in ich da
und das auch nur privat,
Erfahrungen haben es tatsächlich CloudFlair.
Aber,
im größeren Stil,
keine Ahnung.
Zuverlässige Sicherheit, sind für dich
wichtigste die wichtigsten Aspekte
jeder Infrastruktur, okay.
Für mich, ganz ehrlich,
wisst ihr was ich denen
auf diese Frage sagen würde?
Für mich sind die wichtigsten Aspekte, was wir hier haben.
was für euch die wichtigsten aspekte sind wenn ihr sagt performance ist der wichtigste aspekt
ist für mich performance der wichtigste aspekt wenn ihr sagt ausfallsicherheit ist der wichtigste
aspekt ist das für mich der wichtigste als best wenn ihr sagt es muss möglichst billig sein ist
das für mich der wichtigste aspekt für mich ist der wichtigste aspekt was für der wichtigste aspekt
für denjenigen ist er mich bezahlt natürlich sind das wichtige aspekte aber was der schwerpunkt ist
das dürfen die entscheiden und wenn ihr sagt zuverlässig und sicherheit dann ist das für
mich auch so da bin ich dabei da bin ich da bei linux ist für dich das einzig wahre server
betriebssystem ja da bin ich dabei da kann ich mich mit identifizieren ich würde sagen moment
ich muss mal kurz auf die bewerbung auf die stellenanzeige von chat gpt zurückgreifen weil
die trifft hier eigentlich ganz gut hey wir suchen einen verdammt genialen senior linux
engineer der windows als das scheiß system betrachtet dass es ist damit chat gpt mal
gefragt ob es stellenanzeige generieren kann für einen linux admin der windows nicht mag
aber davor musste man davor musste man chat gpt dazu überreden zu fluchen das macht sie
mich standardmäßig nicht ja sehr gut sehr gut dass das spricht
mich das spricht mich ja schon mal richtig an hier du fühlst dich auch im umgang mit großen
datenbanken sicher ehrlich gesagt kommt drauf an also wenn ihr wollt dass ich mich da mit
irgendeinem sql tool connect oder google ist mir auch egal und dort irgendwelche live sql
statements abtippe dann nicht und ich glaube jeder der sich dazu sicher fühlt bei der hat
ernsthafte probleme das ist dann job table wie bei gips
vor ein paar jahren die kommunikation auf englisch auch im professionellen kontext stellt kein problem
für die chat also ihr kennt meine englisch exkurse teilweise hier im stream wenn es mal sein muss das
ist eindeutig professional kontext wobei man sagen muss so solange sich alle beide seiten mühe geben
funktioniert das tatsächlich ganz gut kann es sein dass es community gehe
nicht mehr als im mode gibt warum gibt es kommt hat ffz da wieder irgendwas verkackt um geht bei
mir community gehe nicht das ist doch ein selben tv im motor ja warum geht beim doch
heck ging bei mir auch die ganze zeit was ist denn da los warum geht keck gehen ich kecke ist kaputt
jetzt geht keck also bei mir geht keck in meiner vorschau auf dem zweiten bildschirm geht es aber
hier geht das nicht sekunde nervt nicht dass das hier was muss ich ja das ist ein 7 tv mode ist
das vielleicht weiß ich echt nicht so anlistet die maus probieren wir noch mal
bitte noch einmal keck gehen negls geht nicht was ist denn hier los ich weiß nicht was ist
für probleme hat keine ahnung habe ich vielleicht gibi motzlister okay keine ahnung wo es dass wir
dafür schmerzen hat so unser text deine sorgen und nomad das sind die einzigen die ich kenne die nomad
verwenden. Nomad ist, wenn ich das
richtig im Kopf habe,
die
HashiCorp-Kubernetes-
Alternative, oder?
Glaube ich.
Ja.
Genau.
Das habe ich noch nie live im
Einsatz gesehen. Terraform,
ja, AWS, logisch.
Packer auch, meinetwegen.
Konsul auch. Alter, mein Headset.
Wartet mal.
So, wieder da.
So, das auch. Docker, Ansible,
Jenkins, meinetwegen PHP,
Bash, Python. Das passt alles.
Aber Nomad habe ich so noch nicht gesehen.
Ja.
Das in einem Punkt ist schon wild,
aber, ja,
ich könnte es auch sagen.
Timescale ist ja eigentlich Postgres.
Das ist nicht
Slash. Das ist eigentlich
das Gleiche. Also Timescale ist
ein Add-on für Postgres.
Timeseries-Datenbank-Add-on für
Postgres.
Und dann haben wir hier
unsere gesamten Tech-Stack.
PowerCloud.
Oh, ne.
Das ist mir ein bisschen zu viel.
Shit.
Code-
Zapp-tsch-s.
Was? Noch nie gehört.
Hast du damit
Ascii-Docs gemacht? Nö.
Also ich kenne das.
Aber ich habe damit
nichts gemacht. So.
Nächstes Angebot.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Das hatten wir schon.
Stellanzeige. Oh, das ist so.
Das ist so. Ist das die Sparkasse?
Oder ist das so?
Markant.
Mach deine Zukunft markant.
Boah.
Ein DevOps-Engineer wird gesucht.
Unsere Teams sind Offenburg, nicht Offenbach.
Wichtiger
Unterschied.
Entwickeln mithilfe modernster Technologie
effiziente Service-Lösungen zur
Digitalisierung der Wirtschaft. Alter.
Wie Business
möchtest du deinen Intro-Satz machen?
Da kann sich ja nun
wirklich gar keiner was darunter vorstellen,
was die eigentlich schreiben.
Wie Business
möchte dein Intro-Satz sein, Mann?
Ne, ordentliche
Stühle gibt's da nicht. Da sind die nicht,
da sind die zu agil für.
Stonks.
Wenn du deine technologischen Skills in Projekten
direkt in die Praxis umsetzen möchtest,
komm in unser Scrum-Team.
GWG.
Okay. Lösungen und entwickle
mit uns Services zur Erfüllung
der Regularien im Rahmen
der Geldwäsche...
Ach, so sieht's aus. Geldwäscheprävention.
Musste ich auch letztens eine Schulung zu machen.
Ist Pflicht bei uns. Ist Vorgabe.
Geldwäschepräventions-Schulung.
Da weiß ich
jetzt wenigstens Bescheid, wie's geht.
Wichtig, dass man die Schulung gemacht hat.
Du bist froh, keinen Scrum
mehr machen zu müssen.
Kommt immer drauf an, wie's gemacht wird.
Das steht. Solche agilen Sachen
oder eigentlich fast alle so
Management-Methoden stehen und fallen
mit den Leuten,
die dabei sind.
Also auf allen Ebenen.
Ja.
Unser Aufgabenprofil.
Okay. Als Teil eines agilen Teams
brauchst...
Baust du mit Hilfe moderner Cloud-Infrastruktur
und Container-Plattformen den Grundstück
unserer Projekte und gestaltest solide und
einfache Architekturen.
Residenz-Sleeper.
Aber passt zumindest
schon einmal gut zum Titel.
Du übernimmst mit deinem Wissen und deinen Erfahrungen
eine zentrale Rolle in der Betreuung und Weiterentwicklung
unserer IT-Infrastruktur, unserer
Delivery-Prozesse, unseres Monitors
sowie mit Hilfe von Cloud-Lösungen als auch
On-Premises-Software.
Die sind uncool.
Die coolen Leute sagen nur noch
On-Prem, weil sie da einfach
geiler Cloud-Native-mäßig klingen.
Ja, okay.
Und
ich habe mal eine Frage.
Worauf läuft denn
die On-Premises-Software?
So.
Schon
bei der Konzeptionierung und Entwicklung
der Anwendung planst du den späteren
hochverfügbaren und skalierbaren Betrieb.
Siehste, deswegen
Hyperscaler, Leute. Ich habe es euch gesagt.
Das Wort, merkt euch ohne Scheiß, wenn ihr klären solltet,
das Wort könnt ihr überall anbringen.
Werft einfach mal
regelmäßig bei irgendwelchen Meetings
das Wort Hyperscaler rein und dann berichtet
mir im Stream, wie es angekommen ist.
Die haben ein eigenes Rechenzentrum in
Offenburg, da habe ich gearbeitet. Nice.
Das heißt, du weißt,
wie da hyperscaled wird bei denen.
Du
stellst sicher, dass unsere Services reibungslos
funktionieren. Du stehst sowohl Kunden
als auch deinen Teams stets mit lösungsorientierten
Ideen zur Seite und setzt
okay, blablabla. Ja, also ich meine,
das passt eigentlich schon mal ganz gut zu dem, was
sie haben wollen und dem, was sie hier schreiben. Das ist natürlich, sag mal,
sehr 0815 und ein bisschen trocken
geschrieben, aber das passt zumindest zusammen. Das haben wir
ja auch nicht in jeder Stellenanzeige.
Und ein Hyperscaler, korrekt, das kann man
überall anbringen.
Ich frage mich, was der Bäcker macht, wenn man dort
einen Hyperscaler bestellt, man.
Also, wenn es einen Hyperscaler
beim Bäcker zu bestellen gäbe,
dann würde der überall in Deutschland
Hyperscaler heißen, aber in Berlin hätte
das Ding wieder irgendeinen anderen Namen.
Ihr Bewerbungsprofil, Praxiserfahrung,
Kenntnisse, blablabla. Okay,
also, Technologien.
Gitlab.
Gitlab, Jenkins, Linux,
Elk, Grafana,
oh, ist auch nicht unbedingt
das allerverbreitetste Elasticsearch
Matrix-Stells
Zeug. Grafana,
Azure, bläh, mag ich nicht.
Azure DevOps,
Git, Kubernetes, REST.
Okay, wie 0815 soll
das sein? REST. Irgendjemand hat
gesagt, schreibt da noch REST rein, das ist voll
technisch und so und kommt gut an.
Passt halt so gar nicht
rein an der Stelle.
Mein REST ist ja noch nicht mal eine Technologie
streng genommen.
So, und
Docker. Ja, okay, das
lass ich mir gefallen.
Bereitschaft sich in neue Technologien
arbeiten. Okay.
Konzeptionelle Fähigkeiten.
Bereichsübergreifendes und
prozessorientiertes Denken
und Handeln.
Wenn ihr das sagt,
okay, da hat einer aus der Marketingabteilung
aber richtig in die
Zitatkiste gegriffen, oder?
Verwandle Neugier in
Aufbruch und Interesse in echte Initiative.
Ey, du schickst einen Link hier im Chat
und ich guck das aber vorher auf dem zweiten Bildschirm
in meiner VM an, dass du keinen Mist schickst.
Mach deinen ersten Schritt
in Richtung eines Arbeitsplatzes. Okay.
Ja, also für den Fall der Fälle,
dass das jemand geschickt hat, weil er sich dort bewerben will,
also was ich gut finde ist,
die Basics passen schon mal,
das was sie suchen passt gut mit dem,
was sie schreiben überein.
Der Rest ist aber so sehr 0815,
aber muss nicht schlecht sein.
Ich meine,
wir können als Bewerber
so Sachen ja nur anhand der Stellenanzeige
bewerten,
genauso wie die uns erstmal nur anhand
von irgendeinem Lebenslauf
oder so bewerten können.
Wir kennen die ja nicht näher im Detail
und die uns auch nicht.
Das heißt, müssen wir danach gehen, was wir sehen.
Das ist okay.
Das würde jetzt nicht super
für mich herausstechen,
aber das kann durchaus gut sein.
Weiß es halt jetzt
an der Stelle nicht.
Was ich nice finde ist,
dass sie erst gar nicht anfangen mit ihren Benefits,
wenn es keine gibt.
Ne, steht nix.
So, next.
Was haben wir als nächstes?
Aha.
Ein IT-Spezialist.
Im Einsatz.
Aber sicher.
Kommt zu uns ins Team IT.
Das sieht aus,
also erstens sieht das eins zu eins aus wie ein Hemd von mir
und es könnte auch sogar meine Hand sein.
Aber an so einer Tastatur arbeite ich nicht.
Aber
dieser Satz hier oben
und die Schriftart und alles,
das sieht aus wie das alte Fachinformatiker-Handbuch.
Kennt noch einer das alte?
Bestermann
Fachinformatiker
Handbuch
Ne.
Ne, ne, ne.
Ja, das geht schon eher.
Aber das alte.
Das alte hat so eine Aufst...
Das passt.
Das sieht von der Schriftart und dem Ding,
sieht das total ähnlich aus.
Ist das Windows 7?
Ja, komm, wie weißt du, wie alt das Bild ist?
Was habt ihr? Team Magus?
Steht da was in der Richtung?
Ne.
Was wollt ihr?
Ach so.
Polizei Hubschrauber Staffel Bayern
Sucht zum nächstmöglichen Zeitraum
München Flughafen
Ist das der, wo man in 10 Minuten und so...
Das äh...
Ist äh...
10 Minuten.
Das ist der, okay.
Ein IT-Spezialisten
Netzwerktechnik
und Administration
in Vollzeit
Ja, das ist Stoiber, ich weiß.
Aber der Münchner Flughafen ist das,
wo man in 10 Minuten da ist.
Direkt vom Hauptbahnhof.
Ich weiß, dass ich den Stoiber meine.
Aber der Münchner Flughafen...
Ja, genau das, das meine ich.
Okay, also
Die Polizei Hubschrauber Staffel Bayern
Sucht am Flughafen
einen IT-Spezialisten
in Netzwerktechnik
Netzwerkadmin suchen die im Endeffekt.
Im Zuge der Einführung
modernster Polizeihubschrauber
und der damit verbundenen IT-Technik
ist die neue digitale Infrastruktur
hinsichtlich der konzeptionierten
vernetzungen zu betreuen.
Die Administration erfolgt
größtenteils allein
beziehungsweise an einem sehr eng gefassten...
Moment, sehe ich das richtig?
Ich bin alleine für die gesamte
vernetzungen zu betreuen.
Polizeihubschrauber Staffel zuständig.
DHCP auf Hubschrauber
Da gibt es
TCP über Brieftauben
schon ganz neue Bedeutung.
Es ist breit gefächertes Wissen im IT.
Insbesondere im Bereich der Hubschrauber integrierten
speziellen
EUG
EUG-Technik erforderlich.
Betreuung der taktischen IT...
der taktischen... Tactical...
Nice.
der taktischen IT-Infrastruktur
Polizeihubschrauber Staffel Bayern
Pius...
Die Abkürzung immer, Mann!
PH Hust...
PH Hust bei Monka Tactical
Administration der Missionscomputer
der Polizeihubschrauber
Administration der Hubschrauber
zugehörigen Netzinfrastruktur inklusive
Crown-Server und bordeigenem Router
der Polizeihubschrauber
Koordination mit den Vertragsunternehmen
und Abstimmung von Updates und
Fortentwicklung hinsichtlich technischer Fragen
Das mache ich alles alleine.
Ich weiß,
dass da steht alleine beziehungsweise
in sehr einem gefassten Abenteuer.
Aber Leute, bei solchen Sachen
mache ich das, was viele
Arbeitgeber mit eurer Bewerbung auch machen.
Wenn es zwei Sachen zur Auswahl
gibt, lege ich das
den schlechteren Fall aus.
Also wenn da steht,
höchstenteils allein
beziehungsweise in einem sehr eng gefassten
Abenteuer, lese ich da
allein.
Koordination, Abstimmung mit Betroffenen
Verfahrenskoordination
in technischen Fragen.
Update Pflege der taktischen
Die sind aber äußerst Tactical.
der taktischen
IT-Infrastruktur in Polizei
Ich habe
ein Tactical Tomahawk
letztens gesehen auf Amazon.
Das ist so eine Axt.
Ich weiß nicht, was daran Tactical ist.
Aber die war halt schwarz,
so wie diese ganzen Tactical Equipments,
die es immer gibt. Aber es war halt ein Tomahawk.
So eine Axt.
Genau, sie ist schwarz. Wahrscheinlich ist das
Tactical da dran.
Genauso wie die ganzen Tactical
Tactical
Taschenlampen, die
auf
voller Lichtstärke irgendwie 5 Minuten
halten mit der Batterie oder sowas.
Update Pflege der taktischen IT
Das hatten wir schon. Nein, den hatten wir nicht.
Infrastruktur im Polizeihubschrauber
in Abstimmung mit dem technischen
Betrieb der taktischen
Pehusetby
Okay, Betreuung möglicher
Schnittstellen, Missionssoftware
Entwicklung von Konzepten hinsichtlich
des Betriebs und Pflege der taktischen IT
Da musste schon
so auf Military Shit stehen,
oder?
Infrastruktur Pehusetby
Mitwirkung
im Bereich Implementierung eines digitalen
Boardbooks und digitale Flugzeitenerfassung
Taktische Mittagspause
Du machst Tactical Break
Wenn schon, du machst keine Mittagspause
Der Chopper
Störungsbeseitigung, Störungsmanagement
mit dem Vertrags-
Okay.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was die-
Seriously Leute, das wirkt für mich als
ein äußerst
verantwortungsvoller Job
weil
da fliegen Leute in Hubschrauber und wenn das nicht
funktioniert, stürzen die ab
Oder, naja
haben zumindest Probleme, die zur Sicherheit stehen
Also das ist, da ist schon enorm viel
Verantwortung bei, mal gucken was man dafür, was
sie noch haben wollen, okay
Abgeschlossenes IT-Studium mit
Diplom-Ingenieur oder abgeschlossen-
Achso, staatlichen geprü-
Zum staatlich geprüften
Fachinformatiker
Zum was?
Ist man dann staatlich geprüft?
Also ich meine
ich bin Fachinformatiker, aber ich wüsste
nicht, dass ich staatlich geprüft bin
Ach, das ist Bayern
In Bayern heißt das so
In Bayern heißt das wahrscheinlich einfach so, jaja
Bevorzug mit Spezialisierung in der Fachrichtung
Systemintegration, Digitale Vernetzung
Ja gut, das sind die zwei neuen, also ich wollte keinen
Anwendungsentwickler, wobei, wenn er das kann
Einschlägige Berufserfahrung gewünscht
Erweiterte Kenntnisse im Linux-Bereich
Ah, da sehe ich mich, demnächst
Technical, Tactical Linux
Administration, Tactical
SSH, gute Kenntnisse
in Netzwerktechnik, Grundkenntnisse
Digitalfunk
Fundierte Kenntnisse
zu Software-Architektur
Technischer Sachverstand, sehr gute
Kommunikation, zuverlässiges
innovatives Arbeiten
Wisst ihr, ich glaube
eine Sache, die dort sehr, sehr selten vorkommt
ist innovatives
Arbeiten
hohes Verantwortungsbewusstsein, Teamfähigkeit
Ok, unser Angebot, jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt
Also, Arbeiten in einem technisch sehr modernen
Umfeld, behördliches Gesundheitsmanagement
zur Benutzung der Sportsstätten
des Flughafen Münchens
Ok
Da kann ich dort mal eine Runde rennen
Vielfältiges
Verpflegungsangebot in zahlreichen
Flughafen, Mitarbeiterkanälen, kostenlose
Parkmöglichkeiten, ok, das ist ja alles nicht verkehrt
Ja
Ok, die Einstellung erfolgt in Arbeitnehmerverhältnissen
nach der Bestimmung des Tarifvertrags
öffentlich dienstgeleitet TVL
Die Eingruppierung richtet sich
nach den jeweiligen persönlichen Forderungen zu höchstens
der Gruppe 11
Also, wir suchen mal TVL
Ist das hier die richtige Seite?
Habe ich hier das Richtige?
Ja
Also, man fängt erstmal so mit an
Naja, das hier ist
Die bezahlen wahrscheinlich wirklich ganz knallhart
einfach 12
Gibt es da 12, 13, 14 Monatsgehälter?
Also, das ist
das Höchste, was möglich ist
Ok, gehen wir mal
von aus, da bewirbt sich jetzt jemand
mit
Was ist das hier?
Ach, das ist diese Geschichte mit 1 Jahr
und dann wieder das oben drauf
Sprich, das hier hast du dann irgendwie erst nach 20 Jahren oder so
Also, hier brauchst du
Ohne Brust, hier hast du nach einem Jahr
Hier hast du
nach 3 Jahren
Das hast du dann quasi nach 6 Jahren
Das hier hast du dann
quasi nach, äh
Kann man das einfach drauf rechnen?
10 Jahren
Und das hier dann irgendwie nach 15 Jahren oder so
Ok
Also, gehen wir mal realistisch aus
Jemand, der dort anfängt
Kann ja maximal das hier bekommen
Weil das da drüber ist, erst nachdem du da drinnen
gewesen bist
So, machen wir jetzt
einfach mal
mal 12
In München?
Ich weiß ja net
Die haben 13, ok
Aber selbst das
In München, ich weiß ja net
Mit der großen Verantwortung
In München
Netto, ja
Gut, vielleicht hast du steuerlich
Äh, nee, nee, nicht netto
Brutto, da musst du auch Steuern drauf bezahlen
Natürlich
Ich weiß nicht, wie es da steuer
Wie es da steuermäßig aussieht
Wenn du dort
arbeitest, ob es da irgendwie Vorteile
gibt, weil das ja was öffentliches ist
Keine Ahnung
Also, wenn du so gut wie keine Steuern bezahlst
Ist das vollkommen in Ordnung
Wenn du halt ganz normal Steuern bezahlst
Dann ist das in München
Jetzt eher wenig
Würde mich interessieren, was man da am Ende rauskommt
Aber seriously
Es sieht für München und Umgebung echt nicht viel aus
Also generell
Würde ich sagen, mit der Berufserfahrung
Ist in ganz Deutschland 54k
Nicht sonderlich viel
Ich meine, die wollen ja mindestens Leute
Mit 6 Jahren oder, nee, okay
3, 3
Aber trotzdem, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt
super üppig
Moment, was? Rechner
Woah
Alter, mein Auge
Kann sich sowas einfach posten
Netto bleiben
Stufe 1, Moment
Wir wollen nicht Stufe 1, wir wollen ja nicht Stufe 1
gucken, wir wollen
Wir wollen Stufe, Stufe 3
gucken
Macht man hier oben dann Stufe 3?
Nee
Wo macht man hier 3?
Stufe 3
Ja, aber Stufe 3 wollen wir doch
Das ist das Maximale, was du kriegen kannst
Achso, ah, da ist schon
Also
Netto bleiben
Das ist jetzt nicht so doll
Was, du siehst nix?
Achso, okay
Jetzt seht ihr was, ne
Also
Das ist jetzt nicht so geil
Vor allem
Vor allem für München
Also
Da sehe ich mich nicht, ehrlich
gesagt
Auch so nicht, weil ich nix neues suche, aber da würde
ich mich, da würde ich mich wirklich
gar nicht sehen, ja
Davon kannst du in München
ja wahrscheinlich dir eine Wohnung gerade so bezahlen
Ja
Also das, das sehe ich jetzt nicht, dass das
irgendjemand macht für die Kohle
Zumal du, zumal du nicht vergessen darfst
Also ich finde, ganz ehrlich
So wie sich das hier liest
Was du hier machst
Das du Teilwe...
Das du quasi alleine verantwortlich bist
Für die
Für die neue
Polizeihubschrauber Staffel
Und das mehr oder weniger IT-mäßig
Umfassend
Also
Ich finde das nicht attraktiv
Was die anbieten
Würde ich nett machen, kann man auch nicht machen, aber...
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das jemand macht, freiwillig
Haben die auch einen Obstkorb?
Ich glaube, stand nix dazu da
Ja gut, da wohnst du vielleicht
ein bisschen außerhalb von München, das stimmt schon
Ja
Das stimmt schon
Das ist ja wie im Frankfurter Flughafen
Der ist ja auch nicht wirklich in Frankfurt
Taktischer Obstkorb
Ja
Aber selbst dann, selbst wenn du weniger
Selbst wenn du weniger bezahlst für die Wohnung
als in München
Ist es trotzdem nicht viel
Und gerade für die Verantwortung
Und das du das alleine...
Also das klingt echt
Nicht nach Scam
Weil die meinen es ernst
Das klingt aber nach keiner Stelle
Die man gerne machen möchte
Ok, wen haben wir denn als nächstes?
Jan Stonks
Excellent
Geht's richtig rauf hier
Danke für den Sub
Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
MWD
Mal wieder
Aber
Es gibt ja kaum jemand
Den ich bisher
Der ernsthaft ein Fachinformatiker Systemintegration sucht
Die suchen ja anscheinend
Keine Auszubildendenstelle
Sondern wirklich
Ein Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
Das finde ich interessant
Das siehst du so gut wie gar nicht mehr
Nach der Ausbildung auftauchen, diesen Begriff
Gucken wir uns Stellen in ganz Deutschland
Ich würde mir auch eine Schweizer Stelle angucken
Ich bin im Oktober mit meinem Master fertig
Ich habe meinen Bachelor
Bei der Firma gemacht
Während dem Master arbeite ich jedenfalls die ganze Zeit dort
Zu 100% Remount
Offiziell arbeite ich in Frankfurt als Entwickler
Welches Jahresgehalt findest du für den Master angemessen?
Keine Ahnung
Aber ich sag das was ich da immer
Als Antwort drauf sage
Nämlich
Ich habe mein damaliges Einstiegsgehalt
Mal hochgerechnet
Auf jetzt
Und da ist das
Das wäre jetzt
Knapp 46k
Und das wären jetzt
Natürlich kannst du da vielleicht
Weil du studiert hast nur ein bisschen was drauf hauen
Kenne ich mich zu wenig mit aus
Wie das jetzt da genau gehandhabt wird
Aber darunter würde ich es dann nicht machen
Schon mal gar nicht in Frankfurt
So
Was haben wir als nächstes
Die suchen echt
Ein Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
Die RBS Netcom
Vom Standort darauf
Wir haben uns als IT Systemhaus
Für Handwerk, Handel und Gewerbe
In der Region etabliert
Wir sind ein Team aus
15 IT Experten
Das ist ein kleiner Laden oder?
Tendenz steigend
Hochmotiviert
Technologisch wie menschlich
Inspiriert
Alter
Ist ja gut
Übertreib halt
Hochmotiviert technologisch wie menschlich
Inspiriert
Leistungsfähig
Und echte Teamplayer
Das ist nicht Tactical genug
Finde ich auch
Da müssen wir die taktische Polizeihubschrauber
Staffel mal vorbei schicken
So
Wir sind Berater
Betreuer
Echte Kümmerer
Wir erkennen Zusammenhänge
Das muss nicht schlecht sein
So ein kleiner Laden kann auch echt gut sein
Wir sind Berater
Wir investieren riesig und sind da
Wenn es Probleme gibt
Kurzrum
Wir sorgen dafür
dass unsere Kunden in PunctoIT nie ein blaues Wunder erleben
Zur Verstärkung des Teams suchen sie ein Admin
Ok
Moment
Sie suchen einen Admin
Fachinformatiker IT Support Mitarbeiter
Moment
Also bis hierhin könnte ich mich damit noch halbwegs identifizieren
Aber der zweite Part
Klingt nach was
Was ich im Leben nicht freiwillig machen würde
Oder, und wenn ich das jetzt sage, meine ich nicht die Leute, die im Support arbeiten, sondern die Arbeit an sich.
Support ist echt der komplette Bodensatz, Alter.
Okay, du möchtest nah am Kunden arbeiten, gleichzeitig, ne, möchte ich, möchte ich gar nicht.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, der nah am Kunden arbeiten möchte?
Das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Uwe schreibt, habe letztens eine Entwicklerstelle gesehen.
Am Ende stand, bei einem persönlichen Gespräch können wir am besten rüberbringen, warum du dich für uns entscheiden solltest.
Drei Zeilen weiter drüber stand, schick uns eine E-Mail mit folgenden Angaben, mit dem Punkt, warum du bei uns arbeiten willst.
Entscheidet euch doch mal.
Hey, aus denen ihrer Sicht ist das gar kein Widerspruch.
Die meinen damit wahrscheinlich, du sollst erstmal schreiben, warum du der richtige Bewerber bist.
Und wenn sie dich nicht rausgepickt haben, dass du gut passen könntest.
Dann müssen sie dich davon überzeugen, dass sie eigentlich viel besser sind, als du vielleicht denkst.
Aus denen ihrer Sicht macht das durchaus Sinn.
Ist natürlich total bescheuert geschrieben.
Willst du unsere Echse ausführen?
Netcom, RBS.
Aufgaben.
Administration und Support von Clients und Servern.
Also, ich warte jetzt noch drauf, dass da jetzt Windows Server kommt oder Active Directory oder sowas.
Planung, Analyse, Netzwerkinfrastruktur, Designoptimierung.
Designoptimierung.
Aufbau und, ach so, okay, die meinen damit nicht wirklich Design, irgendwas Grafisches, sondern Architektur meinen die eher, sowas.
Aufbau und Betreuung von IT-Systemen, Management von Netzwerken und Serversystemen, Support und Betreuung unserer...
Okay, da machst du wirklich alles.
Das lasse ich denen aber durchgehen, dass man hier alles macht, weil das ist eine Firma mit 15 Mann.
Da macht wahrscheinlich jeder zum Teil...
Teil alles.
Aber hat bestimmt auch Schwerpunkte.
Das lasse ich denen aber durchgehen an der Stelle.
Bei größeren Läden mache ich mich ja da immer drüber lustig.
Okay, Qualifikation.
Physiausbildung.
Gute Kenntnisse von Microsoft Windows.
Boah.
Nein, Gott!
Nein, Gott, bitte, nein!
Nein!
Praxiserfahrung im Bereich Virtualisierung.
Netzwerk und Cloud, Auffassungsgabe, kreative Problemlösung.
Ja, das meinen die so, wenn das da steht.
Seriously, in so kleinen Läden, da bleibt aber oftmals nichts anderes übrig.
Also, ich glaube, da wird noch mehr gebastelt, als in der IT ohnehin schon.
Und das muss nichts Schlechtes sein.
Gewohnheit, Eigenverantwortung zu haben.
Umfangreise, flache Hierarchien.
Festanstellung in Vollzeit.
Flexible Arbeit.
Wie sieht es mit Homeoffice aus?
Wahrscheinlich bei 15 mal nicht.
Vermögenswirksam, Betriebs- und Firmenver-
Oh ja, nice.
Krass ist der Vorteil ever für mich, ja.
Tom, ich auch.
Ich auch.
Ich habe meine Ausbildung bei einem Internetprovider gemacht.
Bei einem kleinen.
Nicht bei der Telekom oder so.
Weil immer irgendwelche Leute schreiben, ich hätte angeblich bei der Telekom meine Ausbildung gemacht.
Habe ich nicht.
Da war das auch so.
Da wurde auch enorm viel gebastelt.
Und da hat man schon einiges.
Ich habe einiges gelernt.
Ich sage ehrlich, mich persönlich spricht es überhaupt nicht an.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil ich echt keine gute Erfahrung mit so kleinen Läden gemacht habe.
Ich meine, mein Ausbildungsbetrieb war nicht ganz so klein.
Die waren einen Ticken größer.
Die hatten so 200 Leute.
Und 50 davon waren Azubis.
Kein Witz.
Aber das heißt nicht, dass die schlecht sein müssen.
Ich glaube, wenn man sowas mag, sowas Kleines, dann kann das durchaus gut sein.
Mich persönlich spricht es halt überhaupt nicht an.
Zumal es Windows ist.
Die würden mich auch nicht wollen.
Ich habe das nirgendwo erwähnt, welcher Provider.
Oder vielleicht mal aus Versehen.
Aber wenn ich es im Stream erwähnt habe, dann kann ich es jetzt ja auch verraten.
Oder war das so ein Chebat in der Richtung gerade?
Wie groß sollte die IT dann für mich sein?
Da kann ich keine Spiele machen.
Da kann ich keine speziellen Zahlen machen.
Das Ding ist halt, wenn es so klein ist, dass jeder alles macht, inklusive Endkunden-Support, da bin ich raus.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Max, du kannst dich eigentlich mal als Gag-Weeb...
Wisst ihr, das könnte ich machen.
Das wäre sogar witzig.
Es ist ja nicht verboten, sich mit Fake-Daten zu bewerben, oder?
Machen wir ein schönes AI-generiertes Peter-Agile-Bild.
Das einzige, was ich bräuchte, ist, ich bräuchte eine Adresse als Absender.
Und ich will da nicht meine persönliche Adresse angeben.
Das heißt, ich bräuchte eine Peter-Agile-Anschrift.
So, was haben wir noch so hier zu bieten?
Oh, what?
Chat?
Warum sagt mir keiner Bescheid?
Was ist hier los?
Das würde ich sagen.
Alter, ich habe noch...
Ich habe noch zwei Sachen offen.
Die gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an.
Ich lasse es hier auf.
Ich muss jetzt auf.
Schau mal, Verfassungsstelle.
Verfassungsschutz Bayern.
Oh, die sind ja...
Also, die Stelle sieht ja schon sowas von bayerisch aus.
Nee, das machen wir nicht heute fertig.
Es ist 22.10 Uhr.
Ihr wisst, 22 Uhr ist Bad-Getime.
Egal, ob ich Urlaub habe oder nicht.
22 Uhr.
Ich gehe eh spätestens 23 Uhr so richtig pennen.
Okay.
Ich bin jemand, der geht lieber früher schlafen und stehe früh auf.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich der Einzige, der im Urlaub auch freiwillig um 7 Uhr aufsteht.
Oder teilweise, wenn irgendwas ist, sogar noch früher.
Aber 7 ist meistens...
Oder sogar sonntags um 7 Uhr aufsteht.
Das macht wahrscheinlich auch kaum einer.
Dafür gehe ich halt 22, 23 Uhr ins Bett.
Chat, geh.
Besser ist das, was für dich gut funktioniert.
Da gibt es kein besser und schlecht.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie was unzulassen.
Ich habe noch nie etwas unzusammenhängigeres gehört in dem Thema.
Ja, und dann schläfst du auch sofort oder guckst du noch Videos.
Ja und nein.
Also, ich gucke noch Videos, aber ich penne da meistens relativ schnell bei ein.
Ich mache das so.
Also, mein Trick ist, du guckst TikTok.
Nee, mache ich nicht.
Also, nicht abends im Bett.
Ich mache das so.
Immer, wenn ich aufs Klo muss.
Ich habe ein Tablet auf dem Klo liegen.
Und dann gucke ich.
auf YouTube rum. Und ich hab ne
Playlist, wo ich mir die Sachen
speichere, die ich mir dann abends angucken will.
Aber ich nehm da immer nur
entspanntes Zeug, ja.
Also Leute, von denen ich weiß, dass die da rumschreien
oder so, kommen da erst gar nicht rein.
Die mach ich dann abends, wenn ich mich
ins Bett lege, mach ich die auf dem Handy an.
Und dann krieg ich
dann meistens gar nicht mehr alles mit.
Bis Liebke.
Hör ich mir
tatsächlich gerne an.
Ich find,
ich find das beruhigend.
Du wirst lachen, ich guck mir tatsächlich
solche Videos gerne an, ja.
Ja.
Ja, klar.
Am besten, wenn er erzählt, dass er im Whirlpool
wieder 15 Weiber geknallt hat.
Wobei, weiß ich nicht,
ob der überhaupt noch diese Art von Videos macht.
Ja, das
25 Zentimeter
deutscher Stahl, oder wie ist das?
Ja, das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Das ist nicht entspannend genug.
Ich guck mir
meistens, ich guck mir, sowas guck ich mir
gerne an.
Über irgendwelche
mathematischen
Sachen. Ich guck mir auch gerne
was aus, so Richtung
Physik,
Universum und
solche Sachen an.
Das ist immer sehr entspannend.
Da kann ich gut bei pennen.
Oh ne, das hat mir schon gereicht, weil ich da gesehen
hab vorhin auf den ersten Blick.
Äh, Kobold-Konferenz.
Ja, da kann man sicherlich einschlafen.
Also, ein Channel, den ich
gerne guck, ist irgendeiner, der heißt
Isaac irgendwas, glaube ich.
Isaac.
Ähm.
Der macht auch immer so irgendwelche, ähm.
Wenn man jetzt mit dem Raumschiff losfliegt
bis Alpha Centauri, dann dauert
das so und so lang und bla bla bla.
ASMR
Installing Gentoo Linux.
Es gibt allen Ernstes ein
ASMR Installing Gentoo Linux.
Der Wolfgang!
Ey, von dem hab ich schon ein paar Sachen geguckt.
Alter, das hat einfach mal 181,
131.000 Aufrufe. Nice!
Nice.
Äh, siehste mal.
Jetzt weiß ich, was YouTube,
was YouTube-Leute sehen wollen.
Es gibt zwei Sachen, die YouTube-Leute sehen wollen.
ASMR
Gentoo installieren und mich
durch den Schnee stelzen sehen.
Äh, das sind anscheinend
die zwei Sachen, die YouTube richtig gut gehen.
So, Leute. Ich geh jetzt
pennen. Wir hören uns morgen. Macht's gut.
Bis dann. See you!
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk